foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
the premier online speed Jazz tournament
a knockout filled with tension drama
quick tactics and shocking moments
oh my gosh for the last seven years and
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format
excitement Reigns every year with major
upsets and intense battles
this year 12 invitees and four
qualifiers face off for the title dozens
have tried but only two have ever worn
this Crown Magnus makes it look easy he
wins the speed test championship
[Music]
who will be this year's Blitz King it
it's time to find out
[Music]
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
are excited to welcome coinbase as a
presenting partner of the speed Chess
Championship earlier today Maxine Buster
legrop demolished Google cast in what
was a very one-sided matchup and right
now we have an extra matchup in store
for everybody I'm Grandmaster Robert
Hess alongside me Grandmaster Daniel
daradinsky and Donya we have Magnus
Carlson taking on video Gujarati an
incredible match to round off our double
header Robert I cannot wait anywhere we
see Magnus Carlson we know it's going to
be an amazing match but vidit definitely
a formidable opponent he is not just
going to fold over and die he is a blitz
player with a pedigree and he is
determined to score the upset of the SCC
yes Magnus Carlson he is the favorite
pretty much whatever matchup he plays
and we see he takes on it Gujarati the
games will start in just about eight
minutes from now and facing Madness it's
never ever easy we know how strong he is
in all formats but the speeches
Championship is one that he himself has
said it's uh maybe the ultimate test of
s uh SCC prowess of speeches problems it
absolutely is this is the litmus test
can you survive against Magnus Carlson
not only can very few survive but very
few can even put up more than a couple
points on the board Magnus Carlson has
blown so many people away across all
formats he continues to do so to this
day even as he shifted his Focus From
the World Cup which he won to his
incredible domination of online
tournaments we take a look at his resume
there let me open people up on a secret
Robert this is not all of Magnus
Carlson's achievements in his chess
career believe it no certainly not and
in that super United GCT wrapping in
Blitz in the blitz he won all nine games
in a given day that was something that
made him smile like we see on the
graphic in front of us he's been dumb
he's been exceptional the only non-first
place finish he's had done yet the
second place in the bullet Chess
Championship the big difference there
there's no increment in the BCC here in
the SEC there definitely is
it's a very different story with
increment Magnus playing very well
without increment with increment as are
the other quarter finalists as we take a
look at our bracket there the
All-American matchup will be happening
between dicaro and caruana we just
determined nihal's Challenger it will be
mvl who blows through kukesh with a
margin of 13 and Ali Raza farusha
against Wesley so could not get any
better than that and we're not even
through our first round matchups
no we are not we are gonna have Magnus
against vidit starting soon and of
course we will also have Jana palmchi
who is in last second entrant he
replaces dingley Wren will be taking on
Origin era geisi but there have been no
upsets in the speed Chess Championship
thus far down I guess the big question
is when will we see our first if ever
is today going to be the day I mean is
vidit going to be the man to defeat
Magnus Carlson in an SCC match
you know the advice shared about
defeating early world champion Alexander
alakaim comes to mind it was famously
said that you have to defeat him three
times once in the opening once in the
middle game once in the end game I think
the SEC format lends itself uh to that
kind of characterization you will need
to beat Magnus across all three formats
because he can come back even when he
faces a large deficit he's done that
before this is a scary task
and you mentioned beating him in the SEC
format this is what that looks like you
get your points until time Runs Out
traditional chess scoring one point for
a win half for a draw if we're tied at
the end of regulation we get four games
of one plus one bullet chest and if it
still remains tied if it's deadlocked we
get Armageddon with bidding we start the
show with a full hour and a half of five
minute plus one second added per move
then we get an hour of three minutes
plus that one second imprint last but
certainly not least it didn't matter in
our earlier match between MBL and goo
cash but it usually does 30 minutes of
bullet chess and all games count as long
as there is even a second remaining on
the match clock done yet we know how
important that is in each and every time
segment and I'm hoping that in this
second match of our double header we
actually will need to reference that
role as amazing as it was to watch our
first match it was a blowout blowout
from the very first moments I'm really
curious to see what characteristic this
match will follow what kind of Arc it is
going to have and is it going to be
similar at all to our first match
well Magnus Carlson is taking part in
this second match of course a fan
favorite the number one rated player in
the world for so long it's easy to
forget his many accomplishments but he
did not win the speech test championship
in 2022 he's looking to recover in 2023
and let's break down this Opening match
we're thrilled to have Deloitte a leader
in their field as an official partner
for the speeches Championship their
dedication to Excellence aligns
perfectly with the ethos of Chess and
with the chess.com mission to grow the
game and sport of Chess Deloitte is the
official Data Insights partner of the
SEC let's Dive Right Now into our
Deloitte game analytics and here they
are Dania the first thing that pops out
to me is that huge rating from Magnus
32-56 blitzwing on chess.com and it is I
think at the current moment the highest
Blitz rating on chess.com obviously
Magnus and Hikaru trade the number one
and number two spots pretty regular
early but the second thing that jumps
out at me is their Blitz Head to Head it
is an overwhelming lead for Magnus
Carlson but still they haven't played
all that many games 15 sounds like a lot
but not when you consider how many Blitz
Games the top guys play amongst each
other and no bullet games whatsoever
it's a blank slate I can't wait for the
bullet segment I can't wait for this
match overall
me neither and it looked like they
refused to draw against one another when
they do draw is blood but no half points
none in their head-to-head matchup in
Blitz chess but there are more analytics
to dive into so why don't we check out
the numbers here we see oh my goodness
the peak Blitz rating from Magnus
3322 nearly 3100 for vidit which of
course is Stellar numbers from him but
33.90 in bullet Done Yet Madness he's a
monster in all time controls he really
is there's only two players who have
ever reached a rating of 3300 or higher
on chess.com one is the car Nakamura the
other is Magnus Carlson I will be
repeating that kind of information
consistently because they are the only
two players who have achieved this level
of dominance over all forms of online
chess but of course Magnus very
experience in the SEC an incredible game
rate his likelihood to win any
individual SEC game is well over 50 and
that's a pretty terrifying stat
yes because that Masonic he only wins 56
time that's not win percentage that's
individual games that he wins he draws
more he barely loses and well vidit he
is going to have to take down magnets
today and in every single time Patrol so
let's dive into the smarter chess
predictions Dania you and I we regularly
disagree so let's look at today's smart
chest prediction of this match oh it's a
lopsided prediction 20-8 final score
what do you think of that and this is a
particularly lopsided prediction even
more so than the previous match again
for vid it six and a half two and a half
is not an acceptable five plus one score
we saw what happened to gukesh when he
lost the first two games MBL never
looked back well Magnus is exactly the
same way if he can get off to that big
start and if he can follow smarter
chess's prediction in a five plus one
segment yeah I think it's gonna be a
blowout so yet again I'm a broken record
but I'm gonna repeat it one more time
the first 30 minutes of this match are
absolutely crucial if vidit wants to
defy the expectations
well did it Gujarati a super Grand
Master he is such a strong player in his
own right but as you correctly aptly
stated it he needs to defy expectations
uh the numbers from Smart chests say
that Magnus is going to win the
community filled out their brackets they
made predictions and Dania I think there
are a lot of video fans out there but at
some point realism has a set in and only
two percent of the community thought
that did it will beat Magnus in this
match but it's an amazing player I think
we're gonna showcase uh his ability to
stay afloat and time pressure is opening
preparation throughout the match but
like you said you have to be realistic
Magnus Carlson is a safe bet he is
always going to be the favorite no
matter who he faces and this match is no
exception we see over 5 000 of you
filling out Magnus Carlson as your
winner and we will see if
that it will score the upset of SCC
history and I think it's safe to call
this the upset of SCC history if it can
score the shocking win
yes that would be and let's look at the
Players as they're about to start Magnus
Carlson he is on vacation it would seem
but that background does look familiar
and look at his shirt down here he is
looking like he's on the beach he's
looking like he's on the beach in Hawaii
sipping a pina colada having himself a
good time well I don't think he's got
the Pina Colada he's got something that
he's talking into a little bit of fuel
before the match begins did it a lot
more pensive I think a lot more focused
serious mode and bit it at home in India
as well also chewing on something
probably just getting a little bit of a
snack in before the match begins yeah
vidit's background we know it we love it
he has produced so much content he has
so many fans in India and around the
world and he would love nothing more
than to beat Magnus Carlson and I will
say again because earlier this year done
it in the Pro chess league did it beat
Magnus Carlson in the matchup uh between
their two teams so vidit has done it
before he needs to do it again and again
and again and again because that's the
only way as you put it to defy
expectations he's a hydro with many
heads you need to chop each of those
heads off and you need to do it on
several different fronts you need good
positions out of the opening you need to
not allow Magnus to put pressure on your
clock and by all means you need to
exploit all of the Tactical
opportunities that Magnus grants you
because there will be very few of them
you cannot leave a single point on the
table if you want to defeat the best
player in chess history and let's see if
it is up to the task I'd also mention
Robert he's got a lot of experience in
her RCC formats he's got experience in
the increment format he is a very fast
player I think that he's got it in
himself to at the very least give Magnus
a difficult match and there we go
and did it has an unhappy recent history
with blitz Jess he played in Calcutta he
started the event six out of nine a
great first day but then things just
went absolutely wrong for him he was
stumbling down the stretch and he did
not finish well so didn't he would like
to get out in the early stages on a
positive note and we see the black side
of an exchange Spanish it wasn't Berlin
and Auntie Berlin we should call it but
done it in this position black has the
bishop pair but white has a healthier
Pawn structure yeah this is a very well
studied line uh this has been a frequent
guest now for well over a decade at the
top level as we see Carlson prophylactic
move there H3 restricting the
development of Black's Bishop but you
normally see this bishop coming out to
E6 and you sometimes see the Knight
dropping back to D7 in order to afford
black uh the opportunity to reinforce
the center with F6
and I like the way that Vivid is
handling this position and his clock he
is just gaining space on the queen side
he has an extra Pawn from the a through
the C file it's a double Pawn sure but
you could throw those pawns at the B5
and keep up the initiative there but
what Magnus is doing is saying I'm going
after your Bishop pair and if I take on
E6 the healthier Pawn structure that
will be nice for white in the long term
very rudely asking black a question do
you want to keep your Bishop pair or are
you okay giving up this bishop on E6 and
now vetta turns it back at Magnus do you
want to keep this Knight on G5 or do you
want to eliminate the bishop on E6
Magnus decides to keep the tension vidit
has advanced this Pawn to A4 also
preventing the other night from
accessing this typical B3 square and
finally we do get a trade on E6 which I
think will be followed up either by
Knight C4 or Knight F3
he goes to the king side black should
probably play F6 uh he castles first but
if white plays Knight H4 to go to F5 the
essential question is will black play G6
to stop that that does weaken dark
squares in front of the king or will you
just allow the Knight to venture into
enemy territory Knight H4 seems like a
pretty low risk way to pose further
questions for black I do like vivid's
position I think he's displayed a
fantastic understanding of these
anti-berlin lines and he just needs to
continue making small improving moves
like H6 maybe even Bishop B7 to prevent
that H4 you called it Robert B5
continuing to expand on the queen set
and I think the position is at the very
least equal definitely not worse for
black
B5 is one of those risky moves though
where you do gain space but your C6
spawn is a little bit tender now so you
do need to be careful uh that said I
like the activity of his pieces he's
staring at the d-pawn he's also staring
at the e-pawn so Bishop E3 maybe black
takes on D4 with the pawn because that
E4 Pawn is in the Queen's sights and can
also meet Bishop takes D4 with C5 That's
The Power of having doubled pawns you
can send one of them forward and then
the other one forward to defend B5 a big
decision here for Magnus Carlson he can
of course release the tension uh on his
own terms with d takes E5 but that opens
up the diagonal for Black's Bishop that
also allows black to jump into the
Knight and reinforce the pressure on the
E4 Pawn uh when the knights get traded
on E5 so Magnus going for a more
flexible approach getting the bishop out
to G5 and trying to Maybe cover the F6
Square
and he wants to go Bishop H4 Bishop g3
at the right moment to stare into black
center what black does not want to do is
but e takes D4 allowing C takes D4 with
that C6 Pawn is an easy target and then
you need to keep the opponent C6 because
the B5 Pawn is tender so that's the
downside of pushing pawns if White goes
for the C file that pawn is in trouble
but if black could put that pawn back on
B7 done it you can just pick it up and
put it back there all right again you
can just hover then all of a sudden
Black's Queen side feels very safe
yeah B5 B7 if you could even do that one
time per chess game that would
completely change the tenor of the game
Bishop A5 who is right that forces The
Rook away now Queen takes E4 eats into
white center it doesn't win upon Robert
because white will be able to take on C6
but that seems like a better end game
for black
of course white has this isolated Pawn
on D4 the C7 weakness is defended by a
bishop now the question becomes do is
does black go Bishop B6 to hit D4 he
says no go rookie two first uh but he's
Mission G3 in impending threat and is
black in a bit of Danger on the C7
Square rookie 2 is a very tempting move
but it was a one move threat and King F1
will toss The Rook away from E2 this is
not a stable Rook you're absolutely
right Bishop G3 reinforces the attack on
C7 and how many times have we seen
Magnus do this he's slightly worse than
an end game you think you're not risking
two moves later you already feel like
you're on the cusp of getting crushed
this is what he does best and he does it
especially well within the confines of a
limited time control when you don't have
as much time to figure out the right
defensive setup and I feel like Vivid is
starting to lose the thread here
well B4 just making his Bishop uh look
like a bystander and you can see him
fitted's face he's not a fan of the last
few moves and Dunya I thought you were
gonna say that Magnus is especially
dangerous when he's eating food because
we have seen him do that in all of the
events he plays online where he gets
that nourishment and then he is
recharged and ready to go and you can
just sense that he gets into the Zone he
starts feeling confident and at some
point when you're sitting across from
him virtually uh of course I assume that
it is not currently in Oslo uh you just
feel this total sense of hopelessness
and I felt it for the last time uh in my
bullet Chess Championship match against
Magnus you you go down three or four
points and in your mind you try to pep
yourself up you try to say let's go you
know let's get some games but you know
deep inside that Magnus is never going
to relinquish or lead like that that's
the most debilitating feeling in all of
Chess you know what else is debilitating
White's attack on C7 comes from three
different sources and black can't defend
that pawn
and you know what a good move for black
would be Rook to E2 but he did that move
too quickly which allowed the king to
take control of that square because if
black could play rookie two if the white
king were on G1 then white would have to
deal with the B2 threat you wouldn't
have time to pick up C7 so unfortunately
for vivid this is getting quite bad for
him it's a difficult situation and he's
down two minutes in the clock two
consecutive mistakes that's all it took
and the position went from clearly
better for black maybe slightly better
for black too
perhaps now borderline winning for white
Magnus dropping back to C4 reinforcing
the D4 Pawn I think vidit is trying to
get his Knight around to A6 so he's
found a way to defend the C7 Pawn the
thing is Robert that's not the only
problem in Black's position in fact
that's one of a million problems in
Black's position both Rooks are in
danger of getting crushed here their E4
Rook might be the first one to get
trapped
and to some extent white doesn't even
want to win a pawn because with all
these pawns on the board Black's pieces
are completely stuck so Bishop B6 seems
to be the only move that I see that
saves the day against Knight C6 which is
a pretty nasty threat but the bishop on
B6 it protects C7 it attacks D4 so even
if white wants to play Knight C6 takes
B4 black does have a counter against
White Center
30 seconds for fitted Magnus has kept
himself uh armed with three full minutes
on the clock I think he would likely win
this with a Time situation reversed
given three extra minutes on the clock I
think vivid's position is utterly
hopeless Bishop B6 is the only move
otherwise F3 literally traps The Rook
but it doesn't matter this is a moot
point game one is gonna go to Magnus
what is he considering here I mean is it
to lose on time he's down under 10
seconds then it needs to make a move
whoa C5 but Knight C6 resigns
that doesn't solve anything
I think he just overlooked it he could
still go Knight C6 I don't I don't get
it take the bishop
and Europa piece and you win the game
yeah unfortunately for video and another
downside of playing rookie two earlier
is the white king had stopped the
Blackboard from getting the second rank
it is resignation it is over game one
Magnus Carlson takes his first lead of
the match and done it is getting
important for vidit he cannot spend so
much time where he's just he's
dilly-dallying he's not sure of his plan
that's not gonna work out well against
Magnus it's not but that's also the hard
part because the move that ultimately
lost in the game I don't think it was
before I actually think it was rookie
too maybe I'm overstating the case here
the position was still equal after
rookie two but it set the tone for the
end game and that move he spent only a
couple of seconds on can't blame him it
was a tempting move but this is what
Magnus does so well he puts you in
situations where you start taking your
time and you take too much time you play
quickly it turns out to be a mistake and
soon enough you get into your own head
like that that is the kind of pressure
that he puts on everybody but I like
what it's doing here he's playing an
interesting sideline deploying the queen
to F3 before playing the move f2f4 which
was considered very standard fare in the
night Earth
and he castles Queen side so if Magnus
decides a castle kingside we could have
a slugfest a tactical Skirmish and men's
I think smartly starts at Queen C7
there's no reason to commit your king to
the king side just yet because now if
white wants to make moves like G4 and H4
those could backfire if the black king
does not actually Castle
I faced this line a couple of times in
uh recent weeks and I do think the G4 uh
is the kind of prescribed way of playing
G4 H4 and then ultimately Bishop takes
F6 and G5 I'm not sure exactly what
white gains from you know delaying the
move F4 or not playing F4 at all but
vidit doesn't seem too sure of how to
continue his development I guess he's
deciding between Bishop D3 and G4
and five minute time control with that
one second increment is just how we
start each and every match to some
players that could feel like classical
chess because most of the blitz they
play online is three minute flat with no
increment or is in title Tuesday wait is
it Tuesday by the way
it is Tuesday oh okay well so in title
Tuesday which is probably going on right
now it is or just finished then these
players have three minutes plus one
second increment so five plus one likely
feels like an eternity to these players
and five plus one means that yeah if you
have a particularly important situation
you can spend a minute and a half we've
seen some players spend upwards of three
minutes on a move sometimes the position
demands it the issue is that if you're
playing Magnus you want to be very
careful uh about allowing yourself uh to
just sit there for as long as it takes
because you get down below a minute
Magnus will always find a way uh to put
pressure on you and to make you regret
it so let's keep a close eye on vidit's
time management both sides here taking
their time as Magnus develops this
Knight to C6 challenging its counterpart
on D4 and typically Robert Knight takes
C6 favors black because after BC not
only do you get the B file for your Rook
with long-term pressure on B2 but also
uh you're able to grab more of the
center with d65.
I don't think white wants any part of
Knight takes C6 I think it's time to
develop Bishop E2 then white slides the
queen over to G3 and then you could
start suggesting that you're going after
the black king side all that said some
of Black's moves are quite easy if
you've been Bishop B2 black plays Bishop
D7 if you play Queen G3 I'm not sure if
there's actually that big of a threat at
the moment so is there a threat from
that White Queen like what is White's
next turn yeah that's a great question I
don't believe there is a threat I mean
Bishop F6 Bishop F6 so G7 is not
actually under Fire you could drop your
Bishop back and try to play this like
some sort of a taimanov Down a Tempo but
you know a one move threat against the
G7 Pawn is not dangerous black could
even conceivably castle kingside and
white doesn't have all that much beef on
the king side to attack with so Magnus
he ignores it he plays Bishop D7 and a
big moment for vivid he has to spin
something out on the king side
and he plays F4 he's going for a king
side initiative a black and play H6 but
then white will slide the bishop back to
H4 rather than trading on F6 and then
the G7 Pawn is really under attack in
some of these lines look at this bishop
H4 how is black gonna deal with the G7
Pawn as it does appear to be hanging
well I've seen Rook G8 played a
suspicious number of times
which seems terrible because your king
is then stranded in the center normally
in these lines you do not go Queen side
your queen side is too compromised but
maybe Magnus is trying to quickly shove
through the move G7 G5 which is a very
powerful positional move it's also
trapping the bishop if the queen remains
on G3 but even if the queen were to move
Robert G5 carves out a very very nice
Outpost for the Knight on E5 and that
could justify the placement of the king
in the center but look at fitted is he
gonna go uh
bring up the analysis board because you
and I had our head in the same direction
uh we can just go back here Knight to B5
it probably doesn't work out and so
strong that oh the evil bar doesn't hate
it but we're just gonna take on D6 play
E5 after that there should be some
initiative from White and then you could
even follow up with Knight takes F7
discovering an attack on the bishop
you've got three pawns for the piece and
you know the position is wildly
complicated but instead fit it makes the
tepid move Knight D4 to B3 I thought
that Magnus is going to go kingside here
because without a dark squared Bishop
White's got zero attacking chances I'm
also surprised that Magnus went the
other way I still think black is a great
position both sides improving the
placement of their kings but this just
doesn't seem to be the kind of strategy
with the white pieces that's going to
win you a game against Magnus Carlson
there is zero attack zero pressure
against the black king which is safely
tucked away on B8 and on the other side
of things that Bishop on F6 stares
towards that Knight on C3 so it actually
can black move the Knight let's say
Knight E7 isn't Bishop takes C3 a pretty
big threat great call I think Magnus has
this move in his pocket it's also kind
of hard to prevent because black has
this Monopoly over the dark squares
which means that there's nothing white
can do with this Knight he tries to
protect it and Magnus goes the other way
Knight A7
threatening to jump into B5 and apply
potentially decisive pressure on this
Knight
Rook C1 I think might be Forest exactly
what I was going to say part of Rook C1
seems the only way to defend uh he
instead brings his Knight back to D4
that is a pretty clever way of stopping
Knight to B5 but something about this
position feels kind of wrong
obviously Magnus could repeat the
position once and but it would not mind
a repetition but I would be shocked I
would be shocked if Magnus acquiesces
through a draw here a kind of Magnus
move would be Bishop B8 Magnus likes to
make these slow improving moves keeping
the tension particularly in the context
of its clock which is now down to 97
seconds let's see how Magnus tightens
the screws here I'm really curious to
see how he improves his position
one annoying thing about magnum's
position now let's say Bishop E8 white
has a very natural Rook H to D1 and that
D6 pawn it is a bit tender so you're not
gonna get D5 in that seems impossible
for black to make work and whoa Bishop
B5 tactics damn girl
so if you play Knight C takes B5 Knight
takes B5 unfortunately white can't take
with both Knights his Queen takes C2
check will lead to immediate Checkmate
and queen takes B2 there indeed is made
but Rook D2 a very cold blood I really
like that response by a bit of just
dropping The Rook back now Magnus could
play this move Bishop E8 that we were
talking about earlier
and he's improved his position
marginally and that The Rook one could
argue is inferior on D2 versus D3
because now the Knight on C3 is under a
little bit more Fire by The Rook on C8
Magnus massaging the weaknesses applying
more pressure watching but it's clock
ticked down even further
and this queen on E3 is loose the Knight
on D4 cannot move E5 is not a winning
threat because then I can then go to F5
but you need to be careful about these
things I think that shows some good
caution Rook to D3 protects that Queen
great move and E5 from White's
perspective there would have run into an
unexpected pin along this diagonal
submitted unaligns his rook and his
Queen which is good uh for future
prevention of Moves Like Bishop G5 and
Magnus once again the ball is in his
court he's made all of the kind of
low-hanging fruit types of moves is he
gonna start resorting
two moves like King
yeah I say that as he plays it you
called him but look at this we have
Queen to D2 being played by vidit he's
lining up all of his forces against that
D6 Pawn
video with some Majestic maneuvering
here the way that he's reshuffled his
heavy pieces bringing to bear
a semi-alkine's gun on the D file he's
threatening Knight B3 and suddenly it's
gonna be Magnus who's under some serious
pressure in the center not bit it
the D6 Pawn is such a weakness that at
some point black may make him move like
Bishop to E7 but that doesn't look
Pleasant why are you backtracking and
let's look at the clock down here
suddenly I think for the first time in
the match vid is ahead by a very
important almost 15 seconds he's trusted
his instincts he was very careful and
now Magnus feeling some frustration as
he lifts his Rook up to D7 I think he's
preparing to double on the C file and
exert more pressure on the Knight it's
still a position where anything can
happen I'm still very worried about the
influence that this dark squared Bishop
exerts in the long run but did it with
another good cautious move closing down
the B file and opening up a direct line
of fire against the D6 Pawn
and if you play Rook C to d8 adding
another Defender over there there could
be some Knight A4 tactics to the right
moment to be very careful here I like
Knight A4
ah and you're going after that B6 Square
the queen could slide over to E3 and you
could conceive of a scenario where
Knight B6 is virtually Unstoppable and
he's found it
yes the queen size back to d8 and what's
the next follow-up
looks scary Rook C6 might be forced here
but Magnus is on the ropes here
unfortunately I don't see a good
discover like Knight F5 those type of
moves you just take it you'll get two
minor pieces for The Rook it's not worth
that Sacrifice from bid it's definitely
not I think he's gonna end up going back
to B3 or maybe going back to F3 no he's
got F5 he's attacking on the other side
Magnus pushes E5
is there Knight E6 here probably not he
goes back to B3
and again the rule comes up to C6
this Feels So Close Rook D5 and then
Knight A5 just keep bringing your pieces
forward great stuff maybe F6 Bishop F7
but Black's not in time Knight A5 comes
first Magnus on his back foot here as he
defends the B6 Square great defensive
move
and visit under five seconds he goes
back to C3 he's claiming a positional
Victory the D5 square is now his for the
taking because the E6 Pawn is on E5 but
is it Magnus could get his Knight to B6
he doesn't with two seconds he plays
Rook D7 we're in a Time scramble he
tries to contest that night is there
Knight A5
oh there is the end Knight A5 now the
Knight on B6 is B4 and this he's
repeating moves is he gonna make the
draw though no no he doesn't
Queen comes back Magnus making some
improvements now
oh this is a boat scramble
and looking back with no threat his
pieces are coming out
oh I think there's an A4 tactic
available for just a half second there
there was that would have won a minor
piece now we've got a knight versus
Bishop battle and the brook is stranded
on B6 and The Rook is pinned The Rook
comes up to D5 the king escapes but that
Rook can't get out of there it can't and
then it can continue improving his
position Magnus trying to get his Bishop
to F7 Now The Rook finally gets out but
now D6 is under Fire
oh my gosh wait do you think it's gone
it's not under Fire he's taking it and
if he takes an E8 is The Rook end game
winning for white well you can't blame
him for going for it either way he has
now eliminated all risk but we know how
good Magnus is at holding these Pawn
down end games can Magnus pull out the
miracle save in the second game vid at
trying massaging chiseling his way into
Black's position and now improving on
the king side I think he has it he
should play G5 and he does so and the E5
Pawn is loose but somehow this doesn't
work for white no because of G4 and can
black playpens for a win how does white
stop the pawn
if G3 I guess wait he had maybe G3 there
this is just complicated but now we're
seeing Mass liquidation two pawns
against one Pawn on the queen side which
the kings are on this is a draw at this
point this is a dead Drive B4 B4 is a
really really classy move it doesn't
matter how many pawns you have on the B
file
it's gonna be a dead draw Magnus
identified that two on one position and
went straight for it
so magnets is going to escape but
Village wrathi gave him all he could
handle and Magnus barely survives
that was an incredible game and that was
an encouraging game for a minute because
he didn't get off to the kind of start
he wanted in the first game he got off
to a bad start in the second game as
well but he managed to turn it around
and he managed to show that he can
basically play on equal terms in a Time
scramble against Magnus unfortunately
that's still not enough you need to put
the finishing touches on a game like
that and Magnus rewards himself with a
bite of what seems to be Thai food I I
can feel like that's some sort of Curry
but not the step variety
no imagine looking more like a golfer
than a basketball player right now with
the baseball cap and the Hawaiian shirt
he's making me hungry we've been
commenting for so many hours
he's making me hungry too
um I've got some food in the fridge but
it will have to wait until after this
fascinating match we've got another
Auntie Berlin I feel Robert in the early
going that particularly when Magnus is
white and Vivid is black we might be
getting a lot of Rue Lopez's Magnus
doesn't like to vary his opening choices
unless he truly feels uh that A Change
Is Well warranted
and thus far he has a one point lead
even his game with the black pieces
despite did it playing nicely and
getting Advanced The Invention was never
so huge maybe there was a moment where
there was a Winning Edge just because of
the time scramble but look at this
position this is very magnus-esque it's
just a closed maneuvering position and
did it in the first game he struggled
when the Queens came off the board it
was a weakness in his camp that he
couldn't defend adequately and here in
game three that is opening I think a
success once more
somebody who watches high level chess
semi-regularly should know that this can
also happen out of an Italian this type
of structure maybe even this exact
position there's a lot of intersection
in recent years between the Italian and
the Rue Lopez because of the prevalence
of this early D3 uh in in most real
Lopez lines both against uh the Berlin
and against the mainline uh A6
looks like an equal position to me
there's no reason the black is worser
he's gotten his Knight to the correct
Square on G6 he has a very solid Center
but now he has to decide whether or not
to strike at the center further with the
move D5 this move can be very hard to
evaluate
and D5 is on the board so what do you
call it the pawn box in the center where
they're all looking at each other and
now this middle of the board is
disappearing and I was going to say
could why throwing Bishop takes G6 and
that's exactly why black pushed to E4
now D6 is magnus's idea keeping Black's
Pawn structure disjointed but it comes
at a great cost it allows black a free
Bishop Queen battery aiming at H2 and
forcing White Knight to remain tied down
on F1 this is a really scary position
for white and I think Vivid could bring
his Bishop out to F5 and he does
and Black's got these ideas of Queen D7
Bishop takes H3 as well
that's really important because Knight
C4 for white kicking the queen back to
D7 and then I move like Knight E3 that's
quite tempting but as you're
highlighting Bishop takes H3 that might
just completely obliterate White's
defensive resources and the King will be
wide open for a menacing it's I think
we're seeing this yeah I was going to
propose an analysis part but we don't
need one the live game is our analysis
board now vidit has one important choice
to make Queen E6 was also possible I
think you rejected that because of
Bishop to B3 and Magnus is presumably
not gonna go Knight E3 maybe we can pull
up an analysis board now I'll show this
preemptively Knight E3 how powerful is
Bishop takes H3 really freaking powerful
because after Queen H3 white is paralyze
every square is protected let's make
some random move what is Black's
follow-up gonna be Black's follow-up is
going to be Knight to H4 followed by
Knight F3 this is completely Unstoppable
look at how harmoniously how congruently
Black's pieces are placed on the king
side now if not Knight E3 what on Earth
does Magnus do
well Magnus has figured out he seems
bothered he's moving about in his chair
I don't see an easy choice for him
because Bishop takes H3 still feels like
a threat the good news without having a
knight on E3 is that perhaps a rook can
slide up to E3 for white but I would not
want any part of Bishop takes H3 so
Don is there a way to
I guess Knight E5 but that gives up a
pawn it's a pretty clean Pawn that is
the kind of prescribed method in these
desperate situations you want to
jettison uh as little material as
possible in order to keep yourself
afloat uh if that's a pawn and that's a
pawn and I think he might have to bite
the bullet and throw a knight onto E5
the idea is to open up a line of uh
negotiation between the Queens so that
you could get those Queens off the board
I think he's going for the exchange
sacrifice and said he's gone for your
initial suggestion Robert now that it
has Bishop F4 he's also got Knight T5
and I think Magnus is planning to just
leave The Rook on E3 and give up an
exchange maybe put a queen on H5 I don't
know
I think it's a good practical try in a
Blitz game but it does look worrisome
and look at Magnus he's trying to dig
deep in this game but vidit he's up over
a minute on the clock and has the
initiative Bishop F4 I'm with you that
white can play Knight G3 give up this
Rook on E3 and claim that the position
is closed enough that minor pieces can
actually potentially outshine a rook and
it's really annoying when you're on the
superior side of a position like this
and you're already your mouth is
watering right you're aiming for Bishop
takes HP and suddenly like man I'm gonna
have to convert and exchange up and you
start seeing ghosts because you're
playing Magnus and when he's got two
minor pieces it seems like he's got six
of them if it goes for a different
approach he chases that Knight out of C4
he forces Magnus into playing the move
we were discussing earlier and we will
in fact get a pawn up end game for
minute
we know what happened the first time
they reached an end game can he convert
his material advantage these are the
chances that you have to exploit if you
want to stay afloat against Magnus and
let's be clear this position is not
winning for black black is up a pawn
with great chances but the difference
sometimes that Magnus he tends to secure
the full point from such a position
whereas players against Magnus or
against Hikaru they do not get the win
in fact hikara Max have won positions
just like this and plenty of occasions
so did it he has his work cut out for
him I think he can push this Pawn up to
A4 as black here just to keep those
pawns advancing and connected but where
is the next Target you've already won
one Pawn where to next I would go so far
as to say that if I had black against uh
Hikaru or Magnus here I would probably
be playing for a drive probably be happy
to secure a draw with an extra pawn and
you know how it is right you're feeling
nervous even if you're up a rook against
these guys and for good reason because
of how incredibly good they are at
manufacturing chances in any position
now a big question for Magnus does he
want to exchange nights with Knight to
E3
Knight E3 offers a trade on the spot
it's one of those positions done here
where black is up upon SO trading at
least how our coaches teach us that's
good for black you less of us here on
the board means better winning chances
but with more material on the board I
feel like white has some weak squares to
figure out and that Bishop on D2 in
particular it's not a happy piece
excuse me but I think that was another
sloppy move by Vivid I think he's
allowed Magnus to play Bishop E3 on the
board
why is this move so strong well it
attacks the Knight and it vacates the D2
Square for White's Knight after which
after which the E4 Pawn is going to be
under Fire and suddenly White's minor
pieces have acquired a fair bit of
coordination
where is this Knight even going Knight
C4 you just take it and put Knight D2
hitting both the C and the E Pawn can
black it plays Bishop C7 so he defends
the Knight that way that actually looks
like a very good move and I missed it
completely because I'm like most of my
struggle with retreating moves and
suddenly Magnus goes the other way
Knight to G3 hitting the bishop hitting
the pawn on e4
and what now does he play a slow move
like rookie D1 we should also point out
the time situation Magnus under a minute
so still pretty decent winning chances I
think prevent it but it looks like
Magnus is the one improving his position
it's important that you point out Rook e
rather a to D1 normally you could have
Rooks in the center but black has A4 may
be followed by A3 if the A1 Rook is out
of there so I do think that e to D1 that
is the precise Choice A4 still looks
tempting for me from vidis side of
things and look at the clock that is up
a minute and a half Magnus basically
burning the rest of his time trying to
find the right setup he does go Rook a
to D1 and he does allow A4 and it is on
the board and what does he have in mind
against A3
um I don't think he wants to play B3 but
in order to keep his Queen side pawns he
may have to
first of all did it might refrain from
A3 and he does he instead tries to
contest the D file that leads to a trade
of Rooks
and Magnus using some tactics here to
win the pawn back
okay can't really just swap on e4 and
then you know sorry take any four swap
on B6 Rook takes E4 and then there's
Rook D1 or Rook D2 and white king is not
the safest piece absolutely not and the
B2 Pawn is not the safest Pawn
we're seeing just this is borderline
losing but knowing Magnus he's gonna
find some way to activate his own bishop
and get it to F7 before you know it yeah
that's the point is that the black Rook
leaves the eighth rank white gets a rook
EA check Bishop takes F7 so here for
vivid tough one do you play Rook D1
check I like Rook D2 it's less forcing
because you're not giving a check but
you're hitting B2 and threading A3 let's
not forget about that little Pawn push
and magnus's Magnus but with 15 seconds
left defending an end game that has so
many moving Parts is really difficult
there's B2 there's F2 that's hanging and
if black captures it with a rook then he
sets up the possibility of a discover
check against White's King Vida doing a
great job here pausing understanding yes
I have a big choice and let's see what
he ends up choosing he's now down under
a minute himself and your clock ticks a
lot faster when you're facing Magnus
Carlson Rook at four blundering Rook T1
and Bishop C7
recently this is the first win of the
match for viticus wrathi we have a one
half one half tie Donya that was good
conversion from did it what a statement
what a statement in terms of the game
what a statement in terms of the fact
that vidit won it with the black and in
terms of the fact that he's had very
comfortable positions out of the opening
uh one could say in the night off game
he messed up a little bit but Vivid is
able to take these games onto his own
terms that was a huge confidence boost
and I'm sure many people in the chat are
rooting for Vedic Gujarati he has so
many fans out there and he is the
underdog against Magnus Carlson but on
the scoreboard which does all the
Talking there are no underdogs right now
we have a tied match
we do indeed and we have yet another
anti-berlin no you're not seeing things
but yes the colors are reversed now it's
vivid's turn uh to take a stab at the
white side of the ante Berlin let's see
if Magnus film ketos is Bishop yes he
does this is the most ambitious setup
against the ante Berlin
and these types of positions are so
difficult for white to assess because
you want to play D4 but that makes your
E4 Pawn vulnerable and also your D4 Pawn
because the bishop is on G7 rather than
sitting passively on E7 so I like these
positions from the black side Donna we
haven't talked about it yet but look at
how Magnus like slouched in his chair
yeah now that you pointed it out to me
I'm looking at his camera and now that
you pointed it out to me he immediately
kind of sits back up a little bit still
getting the sense that he's on the beach
somewhere you know
it's like in when you're in school back
in the day you're in high school and
your teacher you know tells you to sit
up properly that's exactly what it felt
like I I called him out on it and he
knew it was coming but I think he might
be bothered by the light as well you
could see the beam back there he's kind
of having his hand over his eyes but
maybe his hand over his eyes because
vidis play is shining
see that is an act that I simply cannot
Follow That kind of statement there's
nothing for me to say afterward that
could equal parallel the Brilliance of
that statement
thank you my friend but a lot of your
variations have been particularly
brilliant today and we see this position
it's solid so it feels like did it
continues to play calm chess he doesn't
want tactical skirmishes no fireworks on
the board this early but Magnus just
playing this move A5 so what do you make
of that decision to press forward on the
queen side does that leave behind some
vulnerable squares it leaves behind
vulnerable squares it leaves behind a
vulnerable Pawn on B5 and that it could
challenge that pawn with the move A4 and
I guarantee you that that is exactly
what he's calculating I would play A4
Magnus is likely intending B4 okay he
does something very similar he decides
to attack that pawn with his piece with
his bishop and he could still meet C6
with A4 Magnus could still play before
and he does
and vidit simply continues with his uh
other Bishops development Magnus will
likely chase the bishop away with H6 but
this is a common Motif Robert in a lot
of real Lopez positions you induce
Bishop you induce them of H6 drop the
bishop back to D2 and later on in the
game you could Target that H6 Pawn by
building a battery with Queen to C1
wow he plays C5 I was wondering if we
would get a D5 push at some point and
the push is there but it's from White
and now Black's best move is C5 back to
C6 to challenge for the center because
Donya in vintage Roy Lopez fashion white
likes to maneuver the Knights Play on
the king side black needs some kind of
queen side play but if you allow that
side of the board to shut down if white
can play C4 into the black bear then
white has a free hand on the king side I
apologize that was a mouse slip on my
behalf but I was gonna say the second
best move best move is C5 C6 the second
best move is B4 B5 uh in order to be
able to play C4 and carve out that C5
Square for black snide in the benoni
there's a classic maneuver where white
snipe goes from F3 to D2 to C4 well this
is actually a very similar structure so
it should be pointed out that Vida does
not have to restrict his play to the
king side white can also play on The
Queen side neither flank belongs to
neither side right both sides can play
both sides of the board but it looks
like white holds all of the all of the
cards here and did it traded on A6 he
had two options there either trade or
play C4 to shut that Bishop out of play
and to close the queen side then to
focus on the king side but your idea
that benoni idea what Knight F3 to D2 to
C4 at some point he would like to use
that to his Advantage but wow BC or BC
that surprised me ac dcbc that is
surprising indeed but it was preferred
by the engine and I think what vit is
saying is listen yeah my Pawn structure
optically is not as attractive as it
would have been after Bishop takes C3
but look at that B file I'm going to
stick a rook on B1 I'm gonna get that
Rook up to B5 right now he has secured
the pawn on C4 which Magnus has decided
to jettison in favor of securing the B3
Square for his own Knight but I don't
think he's fast enough is is Magnus
because of the vulnerable Rook on Asics
exactly that if black could play Knight
B3 here and Rook A8 at the same time
black might even be better but now that
it can take this Knight on C5 and yes as
you're pointing out black to play Rook
C8 but that Bishop on G7 what Bishop
that's a big Pawn it's like in some
Kings Indians when the position doesn't
open up instead it's a more strategic
battle you regret that the bishop is
over there that's a total dud of a
bishop and Matt and vidit has just
eliminated magnus's only strong piece
now I would move the queen away to D3 so
that Magnus didn't have Knight D7
and you can continue improving your
position put a rook on B1 potentially
play C4 and Knight D2 and ultimately
your goal is to chase this Rook out of
C5 and set your extra Pawn on the queen
side in motion Magnus is obviously going
to try to prevent that from happening by
establishing a bind on the dark squares
in the queen side and black might play
H5 at some moment and Bishop H6 because
he hears us making fun of that Bishop
that Bishop on H6 stops a rook C1 also
stops Knight D2 from happening white was
like before and he okay has said that he
does it and play C4 bring the Rook to B
once things of this nature but at some
point I think black desperately needs
some play of his own absolutely and
Magnus trying to generate play of his
own by getting his Knight to C5 this
move makes a lot of noise but it's
largely a paper Tiger but it calmly
drops the screen back to C2 and now
Knight B3 loses a lot of its luster uh
Robert because the F3 Knight can drop
back to D2 you called it great call by
you H5 on the board Magnus trying
desperately to maximize the pieces
available at his disposal Bishop H6 is
coming next
if he gets Bishop H6 and Knight B3 then
that would have stopped a knight to D2
but that's why Bennett went Knight G3
which is doing nothing and dominated by
Black's pawns where he reroutes it to D2
I saw a featured chat just before that
did its positional prowess is on Full
display this has been an amazing set of
moves from him vidit is a positional
player at Heart of course as a 2700 plus
GM he is universal he can do absolutely
everything he can play a mean Sicilian
and he did in their second game but at
his core he is a positional wizard but
he's gone Rook B6 he's going straight
into the tactics
and I think he's blundered some sort of
Knight takes E4 shot after Rook takes B6
and he's realizing it now because oh
1966 black just plays Rook to B8 and
there are problems down the B line so
this does not look good at all for white
he's going to end up playing Rook takes
B6 so I'm not gonna put these moves on
the analysis board instead of Rook B6 he
should have no he's got Knight takes B6
and apparently he's losing now
so Rook B8 Knight C4 back
maybe you just trade and bring your
queen up somewhere but I don't see it
just yet Queen A6 apparently is a really
powerful move and there's a specific
reason why
um I'll play the moves on the board
really quickly I think Magnus might be
attracted to Rook B3 a collinear move
but if we could pull up an analysis
board before he makes his move take
Stakes Queen A6 and if Queen to B4 then
suddenly Knight D3 hitting the queen
queen takes D6 get the Knight and the
Knight guards E5 Knight takes E5 Queen
takes E4 white doesn't have nearly
enough pawns to Warrant the loss of a
piece guess what Robert was there ever
any doubt that Magnus was gonna spot
this sequence no and he's so strong that
he is always on the lookout for moves
that turn the game around he trades
Rooks in a pawn down position Queen A6
and you see vidit he's like what did I
just do queen F1 defends the Knight but
it loses sight of the E4 Pawn Donya
black is having all the fun right now
and vidit is on under a minute
unbelievable how quickly things turned
around it took four moves Rook B6 was
the start of it vintage should have bit
the bullet and recaptured with a rook
that was equal now he gives up complete
domination Queen comes into E2
everything is collapsing and vidit is
going to lose a heartbreaking game with
the white pieces does he have any chance
to move his Knight and after Knight
takes E4 play Queen B6 covering the F2
Pawn hitting D6 maybe it's somewhat
Queen A7 it's like Knight F3 here I feel
like it does give white some hope even
if it should be a winning position for
black oh it might give you some hope but
black is going to capture all of the
pawns okay I think I've made enough
references to that uh particular quote
and he's doing just that I think it's
the only chance for why Queen B6 I agree
with you
Magnus needs to find a couple more
accurate Moves In order to finish off
this game maybe Queen to A2 going after
the d-pawn deserves attention
I really like that hitting D5 and A3 at
the same time Knight takes C3 I don't
think that would be a very good choice
because in the White Queen you could
take the D6 pawn and that leaves the
black king a little bit more open so
keeping the D6 Pawn feels like a good
thing a white cambly F3 after Queen A2
so there are some things to work out
there but it's going to be extra
material for black
for sure Magnus so good at knowing when
to slow down this is instructive I think
for newer players for younger players
even players like Magnus when they sense
that they're close to winning they don't
rush it they take as long as they need
to uh to verify all of the lines because
Queen A2 you have to calculate F3 he's
gone for the more concrete attempt
Robert I think he is still going to take
D5 so we're gonna get essentially the
same type of position
I prefer this much more when you're down
to about a minute on the clock and did
it he's out under five seconds uh here I
think Maxwell Queen D3 or even Queen D4
is not out of the question whoa what a
move doubled puns doesn't matter because
of his domination over lights night that
King is it gonna get up to F5
it is King F5
and you could take D4 but that doesn't
matter says Magnus because Knight and
games are most similar to King and pawn
end games and black is up a healthy
extra pawn and he could be up two after
Knight T2 but instead he uses his King
to chop off White's last chance and
vidit resigns the game Exquisite end
game technique every single move
in that last sequence was the top engine
recommendation there were no chances for
video Once the Queens came off the board
but the shape for fit it because until
he played Rook B6 he had put every
single accurate move and then trading
Rooks which sounds like a good thing
when you're up material it completely
backfired because black suddenly went on
the offensive so now here in this next
game we have a London system uh we are
five moves in after Knight D2 uh was
just played by Magnus but this type of
position it's been all the rage at the
highest levels doing the right thing of
slowing down but we have seen the London
so many times now
we've had a couple of londons in the
bullet segment of the gukesh mvl match
in that match I think Bishop F5 uh made
an appearance and then uh gokesh
developed his Bishop to B5 let's see uh
what Magnus draws out he is taking his
sweet time here there are a lot of moves
right you can play E6 Bishop F5 is the
most principled line though and I think
it's been the choice of most top GMS
recently so we might get a reprisal of
the exact kukesh mvl line after Bishop
B5
it should be five it goes after that
Knight on C6 white would like to remove
like after that Queen A4 Knight E5 and
so on but right now for vidic Gujarati
on the black side of things here he
wants to keep the game as solid as
possible he is doing just that with his
Queen on C8 and Magnus doing Magnus
things going after the Bishop Harry
Knight H4
and there are many ways to meet this
move the typical responses Bishop G6 but
you also often see black dropping the
bishop into E4 trying to induce F3 and
only then going back to G6 but bit of
taking the simpler approach Bishop G6 on
the board Magnus has secured the bishop
there and he's gotten yet another one of
those Magnus cagey types of positions
maggots loves these types of positions
because there's no Clarity there's no
obvious idea from the black side and now
that you're pushing the queen set up the
board you can't follow it up with a rook
B8 so easily and you have to watch out
if White Stripes with both E4 and B3 he
chooses the central approach excuse me
Donna I like the look of his position
for white only one side has a bishop
pair and that Bishop on E2 it will
likely slide up to F3 at the right
moment and cause some problems well he
chooses a central approach magnus's play
is beyond her approach I think he's got
a solid Advantage here as he deploys
quite likely his Bishop to F3 now
Bennett is Gonna Get You know all of the
typical moves in on the queen side he's
likely going to play B4
I think you're highlighting the issue
Roberts is that it's not enough to
advance your pawns you need pieces to
back them up what exactly is your next
move right are you gonna play BC okay
but who does the B file open like you
said you can't go Rook B8 I think it
only favors white I think that it should
just keep the tension and Castle himself
but now that whitest Castle casting
makes sense for black until a white
committed the king I think it was smart
to keep the king of the center because
H4 H5 videos do at least look scary and
for Magnus one of these big questions
wow A4
A3
you need a trade you cannot play B3
because if you close the queen side you
have no pressure of your own and the
typical idea here is Knight A5 and
Knight B3 you can do it now now but
watch out for the bishop on E7 it's
undefended in the event of Knight A5
so maybe a move like Queen D7 to
solidify your Center and lend an
important supporter to the bishop and he
and he's done it and now he's ready to
play Knight A5
this looks annoying for white but as we
see in French defenses and openings like
the London here uh even if you get
Knight A5 Knight B3 white will move the
Rook away move the Knight to F1 and go
for the king side I think that white
should consider an E5 Pawn push at some
moment but the downside of pushing your
Pawn the center is you release the
tension and why do you need attention if
black has such an easy opportunity on
the queen side you need to have some
open space for your own pieces as white
speaking of releasing the tension that's
exactly what Magnus Carlson did with e
takes D5 did it recaptured with the pawn
keeping and maintaining the Integrity of
his Pawn structure of course now D5 is
one could say a bit of a weakness and
Magnus would love to Target that pawn
with his Knight a maneuver that comes to
mind now is Knight D2 to F1 to E3 it's
going to be essentially a battle between
White's Bishop pair and White's play
against black center and vidit's ability
to generate play on The Queen side I
think we are likely to see Knight A5 we
might also see a move like Bishop D6
trying to disarm White Bishop pair no we
do see Knight A5 and here we go and The
Rook for black probably has to come to
A5 at some point just to keep that D5
Pawn safe and sound uh there are some
technical he plays it I was gonna say
there are tactics not just on the D5
square but on the diagonal because the
bishop 103 sliced across the board to
that Rook on eight then it just doesn't
look bad for black at least not to my
eyes how does white make any progress it
doesn't but it might in a couple of
moves I'm really worried in the long run
about how weak this D5 Pawn is and no
white can't capture it but what white
can do is play Bishop takes F6 and try
to find a way to involve this Rook from
A2 maybe bring it obviously not jumping
over the queen maybe the queen can move
back but bring the Rook to E2 and then
there's going to be all sorts of tactics
where you can take on D5 using the
undefended nature of the Rook on E8 it
feels to me like a couple of moves down
the line black is going to start
experiencing tactical problems with this
Pawn can Magnus find a way to
orchestrate these types of tactical
ideas I think he's off to a good start
with H4 and I think Knight H7 made a lot
of sense there because the pressure that
was building on the Kings I felt very
difficult to deal with white was gonna
play G3 King G2 Rook H1 and so on by
playing Knight H7 you forced some pieces
off the board white doesn't have forever
to play G3 King G2 and all that I there
is an opportunity for black to have
played G5 or F5 things of that nature so
I like Queen D1 a lot as you're
highlighting Rook E2 Dania this is
starting to look very unpleasant for
vivid and there's no longer pressure on
A3 so The Rook is free to roam about the
cabin look at just the harmony that
Magnus always manages to achieve between
his pieces Rook 82
and now is it time for tactics vidit
puts his Rook on a defended score
preventing any Knight takes D5
Shenanigans but that's not the only
direction that the Knight can go and
then I can go from C2 to B4 it can even
go up to G4 trying to exploit the
alignment of Black's Queen and Black's
Rook after Knight G4 you cannot take the
Knight and you have to allow white to
take on F6 and Black's kingside
Pawn structure he does just that Magnus
is in his element in this middle game
such good call by you this night on B3
it looks great it looks menacing it
attacks absolutely nothing Danny where
does that night belong maybe on F5 maybe
somewhere on the king side anywhere on
the king side but the Knight on B3 is
not doing its part to help black out
great illustration of outpost not
equally good right not every Outpost is
good a piece can be perfectly defended
it can be an advanced enemy territory
and it can be doing absolutely nothing
as Magnus makes a collinear move of his
own he puts not the Knight on E5 but the
Rook on E5 to exert even more pressure
on D5 can vidit defend that pawn
tactically can he defend it with his
Rook what's going on here
Rook E5 another co-linear move we've
seen many of those today and Blacklist
Queen E7 so there is a standoff in the
center Knight takes F6 black plays G
takes F6 so white is not in time to win
this D5 Pawn I think Magnus overlooked
the move Queen E7 I think he thought
Rook 8 to D6 was forced and then he
would continue improving his position he
pulls all the stops out on the king's
head H5 blasting through Black's Pawn
cocoon but can vid had played G takes H5
and after Knight F6 still recapture with
the g-pawn
that looks right because the Rook on E5
can't go ahead and take on H5 because
there's a pin down the E file so we may
see simplification along the e-line that
should be good news for black for vidit
because the black king which looks open
for the time being there won't be enough
pieces to attack it with in the previous
game the collinear move Rook B6 was a
mistake in this game the move rookie 5
was a mistake stop making those Rook
moves toward the center I guess that's
the moral of the story for both players
and now Magnus has to be careful if he
loses A3 black will be threatening to
trade Queens uh shortly thereafter with
Queen A1 so I think it's up to White uh
to make sure that he maintains caution
uh as he holds half a point here
and what moves come to mind because Rook
E3 and Rook takes E6 are the only two
but after Rook takes E6 black takes back
with the Rook on E6 you would like to
keep swapping and end up with a pawn out
on E6 then you have this Pawn chain that
feels nice and protected A3 is
permanently loose are we seeing just
that we are indeed I think Magnus will
recapture on E6 F take C6 and Bishop
takes H5 is a very important move Paving
the way for the White Queen uh to dive
into G4 especially in the event of Queen
takes A3 and this might end Robert in
some sort of a Perpetual check Queen C1
Queen F4 white might be the one
delivering the Perpetual one way or the
other I'm getting draw vibes from this
game
although as I look at the clots both
players about a minute left that if the
black king starts feeling out in the
open and exposed without many Defenders
I could see that going wrong like let's
say you play Queen A3 and white plays
Queen G4 check and either takes on E6 or
plays Queen G6 that does look worrisome
which is exactly why video played at
five guarding the the G4 square with his
Pawn but Magnus re-positioning his Queen
to E1 hitting E6 and threatening perhaps
to implant the queen on this massive
outpost on E5 your point is well taken
suddenly it starts feeling again like
that Knight on B3 could not be more
misplaced and that's why he went Queen
E1 not Queen E2 because if the queen is
on E2 there might have been a knight C1
to D3 rerouting of that piece at the
right moment but the Knight is stuck
black is not moving Frozen and 20
seconds left for video at this point and
he's making that face again that Grimace
right that disappointed gosh I thought
my position was better than it is kind
of face and for Magnus every detail is
taken care of it's like a gourmet
restaurant where the positioning of the
asparagus is there for a reason Queenie
one rather than Queen E2 even that was
accounted for as the bishop swings to E8
he's hitting A4 vid it's getting
overextended here
Knight C1 watching for 92. these are
queen E3 oh Queen G5 E6 check you lost
the key Pawn in the position and you're
gonna lose another one on D5 but it's
not over yet vidit has finally gotten
his Knight into the game Magnus
continues to capture pawns but I don't
think he's got enough time here to
figure anything out
he goes F4 to protected D5 pawn and he
might have F3 if white isn't looking out
for it the bishop comes back to D1
clearly he was looking for it and he's
gonna throw in a check I think on D7
and try to find the correct way to
involve the bishop in a direct attack
against the king or not Donna you were
right that if the queen went back there
with check you would have snaked around
to get back to B2 that Knight was
trapped on A2 it still is and finally
it's captured and it's captured and how
fitting is it that the Knight finally
breaks out of prison only to end up in
an even deadlier prison on A2 where it
is finally put out of its misery by the
White Queen and by Magnus Carlson's
Wizardry in any strategic situation
Magnus Carlsen takes a bite he also
takes a lead of two points heading into
this first break and as chess players do
they stare at the games what could have
been what improvements were in the air
but for Magnus three and a half one half
over Vida Gujarati you couldn't really
ask for that much more Donna
you really can this has been very high
level chess but it should really hold
his head up high he scored a victory
he's gotten very close in all of the
games he needs to do more of what he's
been doing he needs to keep his head up
and he needs to keep his spirits High I
think if he continues playing in this
style we are in for a closer match than
we had this morning
I definitely agree with that it seems
like the players uh they've given it
they're all thus far and they have been
close individual games that come down to
the wire and Magnus Carlson has just
been that accurate and he'll need to
remain accurate if he wants to not just
get past Vivid but win another speed
test Championship we'll find out if
Magnus has what it takes we'll have the
remaining portion of the five plus one
when returned to the speed test
Championship presented by coinbase
thank you
welcome everyone we are here with Judith
Polgar the legendary chess player one of
the greatest chess players of all time
[Music]
and I went to my next room I said no I'm
not moving my queen I'm not moving my
Bishop but actually I'm going to give
Checkmate or winning great material and
I went 93.
it works only that way if your attacker
you sacrifice something go all the way
until the end don't chicken out in the
meantime at some point because many
times there is a point there is no way
back it's only forward
[Applause]
how is it to play with kasparo when you
saw him personally
he really had this incredible energy
shoot it thank you so much for being
with us and I hope you hope you're ready
to to dive into the past with us oh
absolutely I'm very happy to share with
you some of my most memorable games
[Music]
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
we started by focusing on classical
chess but later we fell in love with
playing Blitz and bullet online
chess has been around for more than one
thousand years but that doesn't mean
that we can't modernize it Financial
systems have been around for even longer
sounds like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent also huge thank you to
coinbase for sponsoring competitive
chess and making events like the SCC
happen go to coinbase.com update the
system to learn more
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are back in speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase but Magnus Carlson
is not back in his chair he just left
you can see it's spinning around but
there is Gujarati on camera Daniel we
know him very well but we should
introduce the public to Peter Gujarati
because some fans may not be as familiar
with the number three ranked Indian
player on chess.com Blitz rankings and
that he earned his spot in the SEC by
going through a qualifier number one I'm
honestly a big fan of vidit he sometimes
flies under the radar because he's a
little bit older than this exciting
Young Generation of Indian talents like
gukesh and pragnananda but he has been
really really good for a really really
long time as evidenced by that final
bullet point 2020 medalist in the
Olympiad he has a chess career that
spans well over a decade and a half now
and he is a difficult opponent for just
about anyone including Magnus Carlson
who is up by two as the next game gets
underway here at the SEC
is a good friend of chess.com and he's
also a good friend of mine when I was
just recently in tata steel chess India
we had dinner his parents were there
they're very supportive as is are his
whole entire family they're watching his
matches and it's a big opportunity for
him to play against Magnus unfortunately
for him Magnus is out to a good start
but anything can still happen because
the time controls this is only the first
one it's a long match and Donna in this
position Magnus has great experience
from his world championship but did it
he must have some ideas of his own this
is a classic rosalimo now most of the
rosalimos we see nowadays are kind of
souped up alapins right white plays C3
we saw it earlier this morning
but vidit playing it in more traditional
style taking quickly on C6 and typically
the textbooks advise white to play H3
and prevent the Bishop from coming out
to G4 but more recently uh I almost
called you Magnus more recently Robert
I've seen white fully issue that move
and instead focus on Queen side
development vid it though playing it
very old school I like it
I liked it when you call me Magnus it
made me feel like you really saw me as
the chess player I've always wanted to
be but I truly do in this game Magnus
has that clamp on the center and now on
the queen side A5 played stopping B4 D4
already stopped but these are committal
moves so if white give a knight C4 and
B4 all at once Black's Queen side could
fall apart I would consider the
immediate B4 that has to be seriously
considered and calculated and I think
that's exactly what video is devoting
his time to before there will likely be
a trade and then a trade on A1 and black
will take on B4 and then white can try
to win the pawn back with uh kind of a
clever slide of the queen up to A4 in
order to prevent black from connecting
the pawns with C5 vid it calculates that
line plays before and I think holds a
serious Advantage out of the opening
great demonstration of typical rosalima
ideas Magnus though responding with some
heat
A4 getting a pass Pawn down the queen
side there and Knight C4 looks like it
wins a pawn but then this black have
Knight D7 covering both B6 and E5 maybe
Magnus is just staying in this he has to
retreat but that's just one turn they
don't play B5 kick the Knight out of
there and that I guess is why Vida
played C4 C4 opened up a diagonal attack
on the A4 Pawn Magnus defended with B5
did it traded and occupies the C file
with his rook and now I think the
typical follow-up is to try to open the
center with D4 see the problem is that
if you allow black to consolidate if you
allow Magnus to Castle and get his
Bishop out there's a thing on A4 called
a protected pass pawn and that thing is
going to cause wipe a lot of problems
unless he counter counter balances that
uh with concrete play in the center
which is why I really think he should
consider either D4 or something like
Bishop C5 to prevent black from castling
and developing naturally maybe
bishop C5 there's Knight d seven to kick
that Bishop out of there to take it so
that black and Castle Rook C5 that does
hit the E5 pawn and the B5 Pawn but
Knight D7 still may be available to
Black so Magnus seems to understand
these positions well and once again he's
up a minute and a half on the clock
key is indeed and vidit kind of at a
loss here Castle's King side is a threat
and that's a serious threat because
black will then be only one step away
from fully consolidating right by
developing this bishop
and the problem is that you can play D4
and you can make some noise in the
center
but big deal right black trades on D4
and castles anyway and what have you
really achieved by bringing your Bishop
to D4 Vivid instead takes a slower
approach he gets his Queen out to C2 but
same question Robert that I have against
every other move what does he want to do
against Castle short and there's our
answer what do you make of this
he earned a question mark two turns in a
row I understand the idea but a queen
trade should not help white a rook man
land on the seventh rank but unless
you're winning E5 by force that outside
pass Pawn looks way too much and even if
you do win E5 you open up the bishop on
G7 to help escort that pawn to the other
side so done the last few moves have
clearly been in magnus's favor and
Magnus is just thinking do I trade
Queens right now on C7 or do I say move
my knight away from F6 to D7 or to H5
which looks more active and allow white
to trade on ba
either way I think black's position is
fantastic with every piece that
disappears from the board the power of
the Apon merely increases I think Magnus
is probably looking for a move in this
position of course he finds the top
Engine line with a rook deed was there
ever any doubt and the point is that
Knight takes C5 I think runs in tonight
takes E4 very typical idea in a lot of
openings that involve fianchetto in the
bishop right you expose a discovered
attack on the Knight you recover the
pawn and you recover it with a lot of
interest that pawn will then only be two
steps away from promotion
1985 the movie you want to play but as
you pointed out Knight takes E4 I was
saying Knight D5 but you are tactically
alert that Knight takes E4 is available
to Black there and you don't want to
open up the bishop so what other moves
come to mind Rook F to C1 because the
movement A4 to a through well he took on
E5 he is really playing with fire I
think that's I don't want to say a tilt
move but I feel like he's in too deep
right he has to go down the principal
path you remove Knight T5 looks
excellent as well because this position
isn't it isn't about recovering the pawn
that's not the important thing about the
Knight moving away it's to open up the
diagonal for the bishop so that the a
pawn can be properly supervised but if
you can win a pawn back while you're at
it then obviously why not and now I
think Magnus will stick the bishop on B2
and the game will largely be over
if you played Bishop G7 white plays D4
but he puts the bishop so that nothing
can get in its path A3 A2 A1 I don't
think you can quite pre-move it but what
can black excuse me white dude to
possibly stop it let alone the fact that
the D3 Pawn is hanging and even if you
were to isolate uh the pawn on A4 and
put it aside the other factors the other
considerations are also in Black's favor
the Knight is Awkward the pawn on D3 is
weak and the light skirt Bishop once D3
is captured could start running amok by
developing to F5 or in the event that
white takes on B5 could even deploy to
A6 in some cases I actually think Magnus
is trying to set something like that up
after Rook takes B5 or does he just want
to go A3 and promote the pawn can't
really blame him for that one can you no
I wouldn't but I think Billy is putting
up great resilience right now if you
play Bishop A6 the white Rook slides to
A5 and that a pawn isn't advancing as
far as you would like if you're Magnus
Carlsen and A3 I still think there's
Rook to A5 in these positions and he has
played it but I was just calculating a
bishop G5 move but I thought you could
even throw in Rook A5 first
yeah Rook A5 I think made a lot of sense
to section off the rook and separate it
from the pawn but Bishop G5 is a very
challenging move it hits the Rook it
opens up the Rook on F1 and it's not
entirely clear what Magnus does because
rookie 8 runs into Knight F6 check as
does Rook D7 this was the only winning
move he had to find Bishop A6 and he did
and Bishop takes D3 is coming next
so Rook A5 Bishop takes D3 Bishop takes
d8 I guess it's not enough for white but
it's a messy position to be sure but
look at this line and I'm gonna put this
on the board really quickly Rook A5
Bishop takes D3 Bishop takes d8 Magnus
had to see all of this when he was
playing Bishop A6 B takes A5 now you
take the rook and suddenly you push A2
forgot about that pawn anybody and the
pawn is completely Unstoppable
supervised by this bloodthirsty Bishop
on D4 there's just nothing that white
can do about it Bishop takes A5 doesn't
actually change anything because B uh A2
is still coming and uh obviously this
this kind of thing is not going to help
because the Knight will get chased away
so impressive calculation by Magnus
he has plenty of time on the clock and
he's going to win this game to get to a
three-point lead
is there anything that can be done here
so Rook A5 Bishop takes D3
this looks very forcing he takes this
Rook on D.A first but after Bishop takes
B5 he wants some kind of Bishop this is
clear what he's going for
but I don't think it's gonna work out
can black Play Bishop B2 here say please
take me on that square what a gorgeous
collinear move that is like the ultimate
illustration right you stick the bishop
on a defended Square you say I am more
than happy with the trade but you're
gonna have to push my Pawn forward one
file and you're gonna have to open up
the possibility of Rook A1 Bishop B2 is
the cleanest win Bishop takes F6 also
should win the game but that's quite a
bit Messier
that doesn't look easy actually because
if you take on F6 once the Knight takes
the check and drops right back to the
center with Knight D5 white gets Rook A1
in time so I do think that that gives
white some hope maybe it's still
completely winning but Magnus he plays
Bishop to B2 I only really spot it
because the engine dropped all the way
down there what a lovely way to secure
Victory I would be proud of reproducing
such a sequence in a classical game this
is a five plus one game which by Magnus
Carlson standards is essentially already
like classical and I think he's going to
follow up by yes harassing the Knight on
e4 threatening Bishop takes E4 and
essentially forcing White's hand forcing
white to take on B2
and the point is after Bishop B2 ab2
there's no time for Rook B1 because
Black's Rook slams in the first rank
with Rook A1 and if the white king were
on H2 would be a different story you
just can't get everything that you want
you took the words right out of my mouth
when you're playing Magnus nothing seems
to be on the right spots at the wrong
time Rook C1 another collinear move
hitting the Knight and then the bishop
is gonna snake into D3 that's going to
be the final nail on the coffin Magnus
is enjoying himself right now bang and
vidit is going to let his time run out
what a positional Masterpiece by Carlson
with the black pieces he holds a
three-point lead
that outside pass Pawn as soon as it was
established it looked like trouble for
video Gujarati so Magnus is now up by
three points vid it with the white
pieces in this next game he uh you know
he needs to get going he cannot afford
another loss at all and a draw well
that's okay he needs to show magnets
that he can actually beat him
he does indeed and I'm gonna see if I
can
pull up uh that game in just a moment
here
um let's see here
just a second I think we have some sort
of a semi-tourage
okay so and we'll bring
we'll uh be able to bring that up in a
sec hopefully but it looks like for
Magnus Carlson who now has the black
pieces in the seventh game of the batch
he is taking a solid approach and just
trying to
stabilize in the opening stage not play
anything too crazy so Dania uh for vidit
does he want crazy or what should his
mindset be like it's still early in the
match
yeah I mean it's a three-point lead I
like to talk about the Three-Point Rule
I think the three-point lead is a
threshold if you cross that three-point
lead
then you start entering blowout
territory particularly if you're facing
someone like Magnus Carlson so with the
white pieces 20 minutes remaining in the
five plus one segment this is where you
really want to nip this lead on the butt
and if you can score a second Victory
that'll go a long way toward improving
your confidence
right no you just start getting one
after another you need to play it slowly
and even in the bullet segment where we
know Magnus is a force he will need to
be on the lookout for video Gujarati who
himself is a very strong bullet player
so uh we would like to open the game
apologies to everybody we are having
some technical difficulties but we will
bring up the moves as soon as we can we
will indeed
but that last game definitely a
disappointment for vivid who seemed to
display good understanding of the
rosalimo everything going his way and
then the moment that pawn landed on A4
things went completely Haywire this is
just what Magnus Carlson does such
Universal understanding of all types of
positions
and that's the key is Magnus whether
it's an end game where he's often called
the best in-game technician of all time
whether it's an earlier stage where he
makes these little decisions or so they
seem but have huge consequences and he
just is taking it to video Gujarati
right now he's up four and a half one
and a half but did it he has one Victory
to his name thus far he needs to get
that second and he needs to get it
pretty much more
he does indeed we're having a little bit
of trouble pulling up the game but we
will get that for you as soon as we can
um vidit has the white pieces I'm pretty
sure he started with uh one D4 which I
think is a pretty wise move sometimes
when the match isn't going your way you
want to make a pretty drastic change in
terms of the types of positions that
you're trying to reach right you want to
get a fresh set of positions and maybe
that'll spur you into action although I
I do like the way vidit has handled the
real Lopez's with both colors so I
really don't think the openings Robert
have been his main problem
but that's a psychological trick that
can happen when you lose a game
sometimes we myself included as chess
player say oh I'm not going to play that
opening next time I lost that game but
it's not the opening's fault and as you
just indicated that did it has played
very well in those Spanish structures so
it's not an opening problem even in game
one that didn't end up losing he was
slightly better with the black pieces
than his C7 Pawn was targeted by all of
magnus's forces and it was a collapse
from there but for video Gujarati he's
had some good moments some things that
he can take away with him he just needs
to put it all together and I guess
Magnus you put it all together every
game pretty much every move
and I think uh as you make that really
good point we have it appears managed to
pull up the current position of uh their
next game vidit with the white pieces in
a Queen's Gambit decline a slob uh it's
kind of a pseudo tarash uh was the start
of this game currently we have an
isolated Queen Pawn with white snipe
block hating the pawn on D4 as the
textbooks require you to do but Magnus
has driven upon all the way to H3 poking
holes at why it's already exposed
kingside what do we make of this current
position
I'm wondering if the H3 Pawn is a
strength helping black deliver a
Checkmate or if it's a weakness because
it's extended so far that in many end
games it's going to be difficult to keep
your eyes on and we just saw the queen
go back to H4 is under attack if black
plays Knight to E4 are we gonna see a
clean trade or are we gonna see a
repetition
well I think if if this was game one of
the match if it were probably like Queen
H5 without thinking too much I'm not
seeing a big Advantage for white in the
end game in fact I don't think White's
got any advantage at all I feel like
that pawn on H3 does become more of a
strength Robert in the end game because
it's virtually impossible to Target but
we'll see maybe that it gets rewarded
for his bravery
he swaps the Queens as Rook F to D1 no
Bishop G4 let's not blunder into Forks
white we play the pawn up to F3 and so
the bishop sits on D7 so one idea I see
for white is going Knight E2 Knight F4
but you need to time that very well
because there are some pins along the
diagonal uh this bishop on B6 will be
much stronger if that Knight moves away
from D4 so these decisions are not easy
whatsoever not at all instead vidit
plays kind of a a more flexible move
Bishop from H1 to F3 maybe trying to
reshuffle it toward the center to E2 and
at some point you do want to chase this
Knight away from E4 Magnus could try to
prepare for that eventuality with Bishop
A5 he could try to set himself up uh
with the possibility of Knight C3 if the
necessity arises
Bishop A5 is a really high class move it
doesn't look like it threatens anything
but you are trying to improve the
opportunities for your pieces name of
the Knight going to C3 as you mentioned
there could be a piece landing on D2 but
right now for Magnus if the clocks they
seem accurate he is down a minute on
time he's the one with the isolated Pawn
he's the one with a lot to figure out
absolutely he's down to 90 seconds on at
his clock and he goes G7 G5 advancing
the pawn two squares a move that you
would never consider with the Queens on
the board but with the Queens off the
board you don't particularly care about
your King's Pawn cover that opens up the
possibility uh for more concrete action
on the king side vidit does exactly the
same G4
and you would love to play F5 as black
and he takes him D4 is he gonna play for
F5 he may want to open that file he goes
right for it so he's giving up the A7
Pawn there will be rookie in at some
point also you have to figure out what
to do as white is gf5 Bishop F5 is Rook
f8 coming next but Don is something
about this does feel very fragile for
blacks even though I like it I'm still a
bit worried about A7 and D5 and things
like that no definitely this has to work
out otherwise you might end up a pawn
down white does have this massive uh
blockading piece on D4 it used to be a
knight now it's a bishop the issue from
the other perspective is that if white
trades on e4 it feels like the light
score weakness is on the king side could
cause white rather serious anguish even
in an opposite colored Bishop end game
with all of the Rooks off the board the
king could get imprisoned on G1 so I
feel like this is a three result game
and G takes F5 was vivid's Choice the H3
Pawn is such a nuisance because of the
background checkmates and now it's
defended by the bishop so who cares
about the A7 Pawn is what Magnus is
claiming if Bishop takes A7 maybe
there's Knight C3 for black and that can
cause some discombobulation of the white
forces and we thank Hikaru for a big big
raid uh welcome everybody to the speed
Chess Championship
against Magnus you come at a great time
we're still in our first segment I'm
with you Robert Bishop A7 Knight C3
followed by G4 with ideas of Knight E2
that looks like something I wouldn't
touch with a 10-foot pole against
anybody much less against Magnus Carlson
did it down on time he's at about a
minute left and he hasn't come up with
an idea so he plays Bishop back to E2
retreating there and Magnus says I'm not
retreating I am pressing forward look at
the bind on the king side and it was
crucial to play G4 when he played it
otherwise white would have played F3 and
tossed that Knight out of it before and
gotten the king to an excellent Square
on F2
and the black king is an excellent
Square on E6 in a moment though the A7
Pawn if you leave it there forever maybe
white will eventually be able to capture
it especially now that A4 was played
indeed Bishop takes okay there we go A6
played by Magnus both sides improving
their Pawn structures and Bishops sinks
its teeth onto B6 vidit trying to induce
the trait of Rooks Magna says Nope we
can trade Rooks but it'll have to happen
on my terms you'll have to give up the
entire C file and that's out of the
question for vivid as he circles his
Bishop around to C7 karpov unsecker
Style
now that is a high quality reference and
I was wondering before white played
Bishop C7 if black could play G3 and try
to sacrifice to get a past Pawn but
Bishop C7 stops that idea before it even
can become remotely accessible I'm
referring to a Reload famous real Lopez
game from the 70s where Anatoly karpov
sandwiched his Bishop between the Rooks
quite like this but this was in a middle
game it was in a completely different
type of position
watch out Robert in the future far far
future for Bishop G3 Rook takes G3
Black's got these two Pawns in the third
rank if one of them ends up on the
second rank well we know how that turned
out in the previous game what do you
make of this are we gonna see a
liquidation and a draw
I think that white has easier position
to play I understand that these Rook
takes G3 ideas are in the air but now
that the Rooks are being okay now
they're gone completed never mind
neither side is an easier position it's
just a complete draw and that took about
10 minutes off the match clock we're
down to 14 and a half
time probably for two more five plus one
games
and Magnus now we'll have the white
pieces in an English opening
Magnus mixing it up having some fun with
his opening choices and I always like
this line for white because now that
black has committed the pawn to C6
you're not worried about the queen
getting kicked if he went to D4 and now
we see that the pawns are alive but
Donna in this structure white can hit
black with an F3 move in the near future
and open the board up
I think newer players I'm with you newer
players are always enthralled by Black's
Pawn structure because it looks fancy
you know they've got the pawn on e4
you've got the space Advantage but if
you look more carefully White's position
is very Dynamic you've got a lot of cool
ideas here Queen D3 and E4 is a very
common plan the Knight could sink its
teeth either onto E5 or F5 which is
exactly what Magnus Carlson is doing as
he sacrifices the pawn on C4 and in
return I think he's gonna try to Garner
the bishop pair as well as full control
of the center with E4
and it's like a Catalan but looks
nothing like it because it's a more open
board State and the black king on Jeep
it is In Harm's Way Bishop to G4 was
played if you move your queen off the D
file down goes the D4 Pawn with check so
Queen D2 Magnus does not mind and look
at the next move H3 Queen F2 Pawn G4
maybe Pawn E5 when you're good and ready
it does seem like white has an easier
set of options than black does for some
reason the mental reference is to a set
of games uh in the cgc between Sam sebi
and mvl uh whom Sam Sevilla knocked out
Savion kept playing uh this line in the
English and caps winning games precisely
in this fashion where he would get his
Queen to F2 his rope to F1 ultimately
the Knight to F5 and you know the train
wreck starts really quickly on the king
side so vidit has to find some way to
slow these processes down he can't just
you know develop his pieces in a
pedestrian fashion which is exactly what
he's doing but I think that this might
backfire after H3 and wait a second is
he gonna drop his Bishop after Bishop
e65
this cb6 D5 looks pretty worrisome to my
eyes what is keeping black in that and
it is a piece that is going to be lost
but maybe the Knight on H4 can be
captured and
what is uh E5 and Knight F5 fit it
understandably declines
to lose his minor piece
but now he's given up complete control
of the F5 Square Magnus says thank you
very much
looks very pleasant for white because
Black's extra Pawn is on C4 it's not
really playing a huge role in this game
and so what Magnus can do now and he
plays Queen E2 he can go after that C4
Pawn but he also goes for E5 Bishop
takes H6 or Knight takes something on
the king side is up in the air Black's
position is very precarious man isn't it
amazing when you're watching people like
Magnus how each of his pieces appears on
the right square at exactly the right
time
it is right the queen went to E2 so that
the bishop come to E3 while the D4 Pawn
is defended because the Black Knight
went on to D7 every single move as
you're saying is happening at just the
right moment and the C4 Pawn is falling
at just the wrong moment for black and
Black's pieces are already passive and
overextended I don't think uh that vidit
can can afford to create more weaknesses
with B5 that would walk right into E5
feels like black is clearly worse here
he's also down two minutes on the clock
black needs to generate active counter
play but but against what against the D4
upon well we've been down that path
white just plays Bishop E3 there's some
sort of weird Knight H5 idea trying to
attack G3 that doesn't seem realistic
either I don't really see a move Vida
tries to strike at the center and Magnus
could meet fire with fire here if he
wants with E5
he'll Force the Black Knight to H5 and
there will be tactics so both sides need
to calculate carefully because if you
play E5 Knight H5 suddenly Bishop takes
F5 is a threat that's exactly what is
happening here the G3 Pawn is tender
whoa whoa Knight today
yeah because that takes G3 Magnus rushed
it and he's blundered Bishop takes F5 he
forgot I think that either the G3 Pawn
is hanging or that the bishop can drop
back to G6 with Tempo and white center
suddenly collapses after C takes D4 this
Magnus this game is upset look at him
look at him he just grabbed his head
like what am I doing because C takes D4
even if that Queen went back to D1 or G4
you can't take back with your queen on
D4 because of Bishop c5s
incredible NC takes D4 on the board you
really don't want to give up this night
if you can avoid if you can avoid it
Magnus using his only remaining asset in
the center pushing the pawn up to E6 but
the cold-blooded Knight F6 diffuses
White's remaining initiative and
solidifies a big material advantage and
a monster Center for vivid he might be
technically winning here at this point
and many players would see this and
think white is better because look at
that pawn on E6 look at that Queen on G4
Knight on D5 but black is up a couple
pawns and after Knight F6 which you've
indicated is the best move then you're
starting to trade off most of White's
attackers and there's nothing left to go
after the black king with fantastic
presence of Mine by vidit knowing to
pause at the right moment his time
situation is a little bit worrisome but
I think he's got enough to figure his
way out of this position now Magnus can
take the bishop with check he can take
the Knight with check but neither of
those moves is appealing I would take
the bishop I think that's the Lesser
evil grab the bishop pair at least
eliminate the D4 pawn and try to keep
playing and keep extending the game as
long as you can
I think it's the best decision by far
because if you take on F6 and black gets
to keep those Bishops I would not like
the look of a D3 coming to a theater
near you so he takes an F7 first so if
the Rook takes on F7 there's Queen takes
Bishop on G6 that would be a huge
blunder so if you're going to take on F7
you must do it with the bishop I don't
think you'd take with the King that
looks way too silly so Bishop takes F7
bypass of elimination but H6
looks like it's hanging it's so easy to
blunder something here for either side
for a second I forgot the queen was
hanging and I was going to propose
Bishop takes H6 Vivid could even play
King H7 here that sounds like a Brazen
move but it's actually totally sensible
the king is very safe on H7 there's no
sacrifices on G6 that doesn't work it
doesn't do anything and magnus's
initiative is short-lived initiative
completely Fizzles out he has to
acquiesce to the trade and Robert he
can't even take the bishop anymore that
ship has sailed he might have to play
Queen takes D4 and allow Bishop takes F7
or take the Knight on F6 and that
theater near you is going to feature I
think the move D3 very likely great call
by you even better play by vidit playing
King to H7 what kind of calmness do you
need to just put your King on the rim
protect that Bishop that was under
attack and eliminate Knight takes Bishop
on E7 really great presence of mine and
if Queen D4 Bishop F7 I think that did
it he'll be up a pawn and he's gonna
have a very easy time with it
technically white can restore material
equality for a very brief period of time
and I'll put these moves well never mind
Magnus will put these moves on the board
I was going to say queen takes D4 Bishop
takes F7 very important for vidit uh to
respond by taking that pawn with his
Bishop forcing The Exchange on F6 then
Magnus could take on d8 and take on B7
the thing is in that resulting position
Black's Bishops are going to be so
powerful couples with the Rook on the
open file that Magnus will just sink
under the weight of all the threats
let's see if vidit can correctly
recapture on F7 Rook takes F7 was worse
instead
an even more cold-blooded move Rook C8
it was given a question mark but I could
see Magnus blundering at this stage
because he plays Bishop E3 everything is
loose so there's no Bishop C5 somehow
because Knight takes F6 check that's
pretty huge but actually that light
continues right yeah C5 Knight F6 check
GF you don't can't take the queen on d8
just maybe we could bring up an ounce
for each other ever so quickly that you
could get fooled in such a line
absolutely because after Queen takes the
eight I'll put this all on the board
black plays Bishop takes E3 check first
then recaptures on d8 with the Rook
there was even after Knight takes F6 uh
the Avenue Queen takes F6 Queen C5 was
winning for right anyways we're past
that because instead of all this instead
of all this Knight takes D5 Queen takes
D5 much simpler line that they're going
down and Bishop C5 by vidit forcing the
trade of dark squid Bishops
but it looks like Magnus
is starting to improve not even starting
to improve his position is black even
better anymore
I don't think so especially given the
clock situation the fact that it's an F7
so Vidant he needed to be accurate he
was not and now he needs to avoid a loss
when he is
13.9 seconds on his clock this is
ridiculous Magnus takes these lost
positions Vita didn't take on F7 and now
not only is he regretting not taking F7
he might never be able to take on F7 in
the future because Magnus is going to
cling to that pawn with his teeth oh and
he made a losing move so Bishop C5 Rook
C5 what does he want uh rookie eight
he wins Magnus wins how did he do that I
was gonna ask the same question did it
I'm sure is asking that and then it
makes a move with just 1.2 seconds and
Rook HH and a new queen of peers and a
bishop disappears
that's it this is too easy there's too
many pawns for there to be any Taco of a
fortress
unbelievable now if you can't win these
games
you're done in the match and and that is
just a total Heartbreaker for vivid who
played so well to defuse magnus's
initiative get a winning position and
then he didn't take on F7 guess what
Robert that pawn ultimately became a
queen
that pawn reached the other side and
right now Magnus Carlson has a four
point lead over vidit guzrathi he is
just cruising but it's been a bumpy ride
that's been clear but somehow visit even
when he's up a pawn
he just can't put Magnus away because
Magnus is that resourceful he really is
and even when it seems like he's
blundered or he's lost he's still always
up on time he always has at least one
thing going for him in a particular
position
if he's worth subjectively then the
position remains complicated if he's
worse objectively in the position isn't
complicated then his opponent has two
seconds something always goes wrong for
you when you're trying to convert an
advantage against Magnus Carlson I love
what I'm seeing a king's Indian and a
structure that I am very well familiar
with kind of a morosi bind against the
king's Indian
and the bind means that black can't
easily play B5 or D5 but that E4 pawn it
does stick out and black can Target that
so here in this position white I think
typically says F3 just to keep the
center firmly under his control yeah F3
is kind of a sin Quan on of these types
of positions you don't want to
constantly have to deal uh with the
possibility of H6 and G5 okay rookie one
is also possible you can try to drop the
bishop back to F1 and play without F3
but I'm a little bit skeptical and
Magnus could consider actually H6 G5 and
Knight takes C4 I wouldn't rule that
option out especially given how
adventurous Magna seems to be feeling
today
I think that's a very legitimate try for
black and HX was indeed the choice and
if you play Bishop H4 and G5 happens
isn't black just going to Simply steal
the E4 Pawn there's no useful
discoveries which is why I don't
understand that it's choice of rookie
one I mean F3 doesn't really have all
that many downsides uh in this
particular structure now that it has
opened itself up to a world of hurt down
the e-file what he might have overlooked
is that if he moves his Bishop away
pinning the Knight the Knight can still
take on C3 because the queen on D1 is
targeted this is a very classic trick uh
in these King's Indian structures where
is White's compensation is my question
Knight takes E4 Queen takes E4 that
Queen is in danger on the E file but the
D4 Knight is loose so you'd have to
spend a Tempo saving that piece in which
case you are in big trouble so right now
that it is calculating but Donna I hate
this position for white you're going to
be down a pawn and you'll be lucky to
have full compensation and not to keep
harping on it but I just hate that this
was unnecessary right avid's thinking
right now why on Earth did I allow it
right why am I even in this situation to
begin with I could have played F3
enjoyed myself a nice slight Advantage
instead he's got a search for
compensation where there is none to be
found if he trades on e4 the queen
recaptures hits the Knight he's gonna
have to waste another Tempo I like
Bishop F3 I think this does keep
relatively speaking some semblance of an
initiative
magnus's piece is still disjointed but
the Rook has to escape the seventh rank
now and move back to a far more passive
residence on E3 or E2 that's second one
because the Rook drops back black can
play Rook d8 to defend the D6 Pawn which
is under threat and eventually get the
bishop out of C8 so black is up upon
white has more coordination for the time
being I'd rather be up the pawn though
absolutely and Magnus has a lot of ways
that he can continue improving he can
play Knight C7 and you know what the
best thing is about being up upon you
can give it back at the right moment
with interest so even if you give D6
back at some point it doesn't mean
they're going to be worse maybe you're
even gonna be better what do you see
Bishop takes D4 and Knight C2 actually
that that is tricking yourself I think
we should show this A3 yeah do not play
Bishop takes D4
Knight C2 Rook takes D6 beautiful and
you pay the price for not having your
Rooks coordinated
and white wins
and look what's happening in the game he
went night before and after A3 he
dropped his Knight back done you know so
this is not what Magnus really signed up
for why would you bring your knight to
B4 only allow it to be kicked back
suddenly Vidant has the upper hand
apparently C5 was the only way to
justify the placement of the Knight but
that's such a difficult idea then Knight
c294 this is computer stuff Magnus
instead brought his night bag gave it to
Tempe and vidit uses these Tempe to shut
this Knight down forcing it to seek an
alternate pathway but Vida could now
continue continue to increase the queen
side pressure with B5 really making the
most out of these Tempe that he's been
granted
our B5 such a nice move and it was just
played by vidit if black plays C5 now
you have this permanent weakness on D6
the bishop on F3 stares all the way
through to B7 The Rook in the corner is
not helping out so C5 Knight B3 you
threaten to win the C5 Pawn directly
Knight B3 is such an important move I
think a lot of people uh would get
really wide-eyed at the possibility of
getting the Knight to D5 and they would
play Knight C2 but that's not the best
use of your resources the best use of
your resources is to threaten Knight
takes C5 is to Target Black's Pawn chain
with everything that you got and
magnus's position for the second game in
a row is essentially starting to crumble
vidit has to capitalize this time you
see Magnus right there he's annoyed with
himself he didn't see this coming now
Knight takes E5 will be a free Pawn the
D6 Pawn is hanging directly you can't
play B6 because your Rook is hanging on
A8 so I don't really see a very
attractive move from Magnus maybe he
just has to give up the D6 Pawn but he
does it in the way they also gives up B7
and let's see
now what does vivid start with Bishop
takes D6 is the instinctive move it hits
the Knight you save Bishop takes B7 for
a rainy day or for the next move
depending what black does
that rainy day has arrived it actually
is
drizzling earlier today but not anymore
you were checking out the weather in
your area but look at this position did
it it says he's got a winning Advantage
the bar is very high up there
is Bishop takes D6 just that strong
I guess it is time for the night to go
to the bar after Bishop takes D6 because
its days are probably numbered I think
the point is after Bishop d698 the other
Bishop captures B7 and the tactics work
out in White's favor because you're
gonna take the rook in the corner and
Black's other Rook is going to be over
extended between having to recapture the
bishop and having to defend the Knight
so I think vidit is probably devoting
his time to calculating Bishop D6 Knight
B5
but even there you might have Bishop
takes B7 he takes with the Rook instead
and a lot of his Advantage has uh left
the eval bar so in not the right move
from vidit but also I think it's hard
for Magnus to deal with this because
White's pieces still look very strong
no there's no question that white is
still much better
black has to decide whether and when
he's playing this tactical move Knight
takes B5 if you do it now you're
allowing white to take on E6 and get two
pieces for a rug that looks very
unappealing to me although black will
get a pass seep on at the end of the
line so that's one option another option
is to First Take on D6 and then take on
B5
that leads to a mass liquidation which
has to be properly assessed as well
although that could be the same thing
with white playing Rook takes E6 to
remove the Bishop from the knights
diagonal on B3 so it's gonna get
complicated here the good news for
madness is he started the turn up a lot
of time but didn't he is calculating
quite intensely man people don't talk
about magnus's time management enough it
see it literally seems like he has more
time than his opponent to begin the game
right he's spending
less time than his opponent putting it
to better use and then you look up and
he's still up on time even though it
appears that he's spending two minutes a
move it's crazy it's like when you've
got Leonel Messi on your team and you
feel like you've got more than 11 men on
the field it's the same kind of effect
well having more than 11 men feel is
cheating that's what I that is true and
I see that this feature chat is also
true the problem is no matter what you
do magnets counter attacks are
unbelievable he is very strong at that
part of the game and look at this he
counters by retreating and it takes this
Pawn on C4 so Bishop B7 Rook to d8 only
safe Square
what happens next where Bishop C6
retreating defending attacking on E8 but
Magnus involves the Knight to D6
crazy tactics here with one minute for
both sides
Knight A5
Bishop takes B5 oh Bishop takes D6 and
Bishop E7 I think
oh goodness that is no
that's my incredible line and we might
see that line on the board sorry that's
so easy to overlook
and I think Magnus has overlooked it
Bishop B5 Bishop D6 Bishop C6 and Magnus
thinks I'm safe if you take I take but
Bishop E7 first and only now do you take
on C6 boop boop black is going to drop
an exchange and bit it missed it he was
winning on the spot with Bishop takes D6
what's going on in the game Rook d194
what is happening
so all the pieces are hanging the bishop
on B5 the Knight on e4 the Knight on A5
and the 94 attacks that Bishop on C5 for
good measure but white could only
capture one piece at a time right the
same piece was attacking two different
minor pieces so black could not black
was not losing a piece black is losing a
pawn though
and vidit now has I think excellent
chances to convert this outside passer
on A3 finally we can take a breath
and I think that white needs to play
Bishop C5 to B4 I do like the move G4
from Vivid he is trying to keep Black's
kingside Pawns in check and now he
should probably brings Bishop back to C2
start pushing the a pawn
I agree I think that's the top priority
he prioritizes something different he
brings his King up to the center Magnus
says nope you are not going anywhere
past F3 H5 is a great heads up defensive
move simplifying the situation and now
blockading the a pawn
feels like Magnus is
feels like a 50 50 position
yeah because Bishop D4 check that seems
to be unacceptable for black to allow us
because F6 uh but after Bishop D4 the
black Bishop Retreats and how does white
finally make progress you need to get
your king towards the C2 Square so you
can trade light score Bishops yeah and
King T3 itself alone is not going to do
anything obviously Magnus was important
yesterday
he's going to keep both of his Bishops
on the board unless he feels that a
bishop end game is drawn which it's not
I think he's gonna go Bishop B2 and try
to Anchor himself to this A3 Pawn making
it as hard as possible for white to make
any sort of progress
and so the King goes to D3 now and it's
going up to C4 it does feel like White's
Making Progress is Bishop B7 Bishop A6
Bishop B5 comes to mind at the right
moment it feels like there's going to be
some sort of maneuver either Bishop
before Bishop C2 or this bishop B7
Bishop A6 thing if Whitehead instead
gone to uh C4 but look at Magnus King T6
oh
and can he now trade
oh that's so difficult especially with
no time in the clock and he made that
move with point eight seconds Donya
and he pre-moves F takes E5 giving
giving himself a little bit of cushion
apparently this is winning but it's so
hard to figure out vid it also doesn't
have any time
now how can you figure out a win in this
position there's only a couple pounds
remaining for black and three for
whatever King B4 just magnets do not
take this Pawn on A4
because that would lead to a lost part
end game he will only take this Pawn if
he can take it with his King
and he Bishop C2 not allowing the white
king off the board that is essential
that was gorgeous Robert first the
bishop was on D5 then it landed on C2 in
either case the square that you always
want to control is E4 if you control E4
the pawn controls D4 and the rest is
obviously Mouse slipped what did he just
do he allowed the king up why did he
kill like open should be through
yeah he's losing because the white king
just gobbles up the pawns and he resigns
unbelievable
just Unleashed his potential he steals
an end game from the best ending player
of all time and Magnus Carlson still
leads this match but instead of leading
by four it's down to three that was
incredible persistence from vidit he
missed a win earlier in the game but it
didn't matter he wins in the end he
pulls a Magnus on Magnus himself and he
sets the tone for what needs to be a
highly successful three plus one segment
great final game
okay but Magnus Carlsen leads by six to
three so Donna you see that Gap is still
a big lead for Magnus who do you think
is feeling particularly good about how
that segment concluded listen it's a big
lead for Magnus I think Magnus is going
to be annoyed at the two games that he
lost I don't think he's going to be
another score I think he took care of
business at three point lead after the
five plus one segment is a great score
at the same time vidit is within
Striking Distance this is clearly not
the kind of blowout that we saw in the
morning the level of Chess is very high
and anything can happen Magnus is making
some blunders so I really think that
vidit is going to keep his hopes up and
if he can keep his level up I think we
might be in very closer match than
anybody might have expected
yes but it can keep his cool and keep
the match close in the bullet in
particular anything can happen but this
event does not happen without our
presenting sponsor in coinbase do you
wish Financial systems were as fast and
smart as the 2023 speeches Championship
presented by coinbase they can be check
out coinbase.com update the system today
or use the command coinbase in chat to
learn more again use the command
coinbase we do shout out the presenting
sponsor and well we shout out to five
minute plus one second income segment
that is done with we will take a break
but when returned it's more from the
speed test Championship presented by
coinbase it's Magnus Carlson versus
Russia
foreign
why did you on passant bro I swear to
God ompeson should be enforced all my
friends watching and this is taking
forever play faster if I could move this
poem backwards it would basically be
Checkmate oh and draws are dumb I should
be able to flag him no matter how many
times I repeat moves 1400 years and it's
the same game every time you
know what it's time for some updates I'm
tired of this I'm I'm doing it stalemate
is now a win for the player who gets
stalemated you're welcome Eric Rosen hey
it's the Rosen trout pawns can move
backwards why is that and never not been
a rule pawns come backwards now every
piece should be allowed to on passant
what that's not impossible how ship it
dunzo update enter
Wiseman ending there's just two kings on
the board what is this Purgatory this is
so awesome what we're doing here guys
we're changing chess why can't people
just move however they want whenever
they want
[Music]
four actually explode
pawns are weak no more pawns can promote
on the first move update take down
I'm not sure I made the users as happy
as I thought I would maybe chess doesn't
need an update Financial systems do need
an update though coinbase is working on
just that re-envisioning an entirely new
Financial system that is decentralized
and fully transparent thank you coinbase
for sponsoring competitive chess and
making events like the speed Chess
Championship possible go to coinbase.com
update the system today to learn more
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
talking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
the battleheart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
egg Gollum
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her foes fear her you'll need to
bring your A game if you want to be this
witch
yes that probably is a rabbit up his
sleeve or a huge Fireball with your name
on it we hear Wizards are pretty good at
chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare
play them all on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
the premier online speed chess
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments
oh my gosh for the last seven years and
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format
excitement rains every year with major
upsets and intense battles
this year 12 invitees and four
qualifiers face off for the title dozens
have tried but only two have ever worn
this Crown Magnus makes it look easy
wins the speed test championship
[Music]
who will be this year's Blitz King
it's time to find out
[Music]
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase if
you thought this is just another event
for Magnus think again he is the
two-time speed chess champion he may be
getting a little doze in there getting a
little nap but when it comes to the
speed test Championship he gives it is
all Donya when Magnus was interviewed he
had this to say about the SEC the speed
test Championship is by far my favorite
event on chess.com it's sort of the
Pinnacle of speed chess and a tournament
that shows who's who I'm excited to be
participating again and we'll try to do
even better than last time we know what
happened in 2022 hitkara Nakamura
defeated Magnus in the Epic finale Donna
Magnus wants to do better he's off to a
great start
is honestly great for you know the best
player in chess history to say these
things about the SEC if Magnus takes the
tournament seriously then you know
everybody is going to take it seriously
and they do and Magnus he's irritated
and annoyed at every game that he loses
in the SEC he wants to win this
tournament and I think he's shown that
drive in the first 90 minutes of his
match against vidit but he's got a lot
more work to do as the three plus one
segment gets underway
let's dive right into the action as
Magnus Carlson leads by three points he
did let an end game get away from him he
had the right drawing defense he had a
fortress that he doesn't even believe in
to begin with but he should have made a
draw with proper play He Slipped vidit
takes a win and now it's six to three so
Daniel heading into the three plus one
here do you think that vidit's going to
mix up his openings because he can't
keep the status quo I think he should I
I in general I always err on the side uh
of mixing up the openings and trying to
get different positions particularly if
you're on the losing side of the match
if you're Magnus he can play literally
anything and he is playing literally
everything we see a type of opening that
we haven't had yet this match a type of
structure uh that sometimes happens in
the London but this originated out of a
kind of Catalan slav mixture and a big
decision in the early going typically
you do not see black trading Queens in
this version I think
no Queen A6 that is a good move
usually I was gonna say it's a good
movement but the engine gives it a
question mark So what do I know I think
the problem is that white hasn't castled
yet so white people like Bishop F1 right
now and E4 is a monster threat do you
think he finds that move Bishop F1
threatening E4
I think he does because normally the
white king is castled when black plays
the queen out to Ace
he goes for it
now wait a second this is a very serious
threat and the problem to add insult to
injury if black sticks night on e4 white
can still uh extract a lot of the
benefit of that Discovery with E3 and
the queen cannot depart the B7 pawn and
if black plays B5 you're bang on B5 uh
with a fork coming in with the bishop
this is like seriously bad for black
why is the this remotely acceptable it
feels like E4 is a big threat and as you
mentioned E3 can happen so he starts
with B5 which I think is a good idea
because if white plays A4 black can't
take on A4 you mustn't give up the pawn
the B4 Square that's actually what
happens in some slav openings
yeah A4 is met with B4 just to keep
things close to put a Band-Aid over the
queen side so that you can quickly
complete your king side development
you're gonna need a lot of Band-Aids to
patch up This Disaster that's unfolding
on the king side but Magnus kind of
making a typical Magnus move Bishop F4
maybe not the best according to the
engine but he's playing more
positionally clamping down on the E5
square and I think he's not necessarily
hurrying with A4 he might play it on
this move he might also just play Bishop
back to G2 and complete his development
which he's which he's doing
yes so he's claiming perhaps that
there's a positional plus that the pawn
on B7 made C6 feel safer but for vidit
now that there's no threats on that
diagonal and he brings his Queen back he
can always protect his Pawn with A6 if
he really needs uh an extra Defender
there he can play B4 to gain space if
white plays A4 and of course black can
play Bishop E7 castle kingside and then
play G5 get that Bishop off the B8
Square wow Vince just going forward with
A5 first I don't see why he's worse
anymore
he's not and A4 has lost all of its
luster in fact it's counterproductive
due to B4 and white is going to have
problems keeping the E4 Square Under
Wraps I actually would go so far as to
say that I kind of like that it's
positioned now
I'm with you because that Bishop on F4
it's gonna get kicked at the right
moment not a single Pawn has been traded
let's repeat that not one Pawn has been
traded in this game which makes the
board feel very clogged so what are the
plans that you see Dania for white in
this position well there's only one
right one wise man said the side that
controls the pawn breaks controls the
position and the only conceivable Pawn
break now this is a typical plan in such
positions is uh carrying out E2 E4 which
is clearly what Magnus is preparing
first he's got to decide where to put a
screen he puts it on before
and is he going to follow up with E4
that's an incredibly committal move
because after the trade on e4 the D5
square is weakened and you do not want
to allow black to sink his teeth into
that square so you got to tread very
carefully here Knight he's threatening
to win a piece knight A6 oh and the
queen goes to A3 there's B4 and as
you're pointing out Bishop d8 to A5 but
why didn't wince he made the move Knight
to B8 and then it seemed like he didn't
like his decision
is it because of magnus's response
Knight C3 to D1 vacating an escape
Square for the White Queen this is not
exactly you know a reason to
um I don't know it's a cry
but it may be the case that it is in a
bit of a dead end with this Knight on A6
kind of having no prospects past A6
and he just castles there's no Bishop
takes H6 funny business white doesn't
have enough pieces over there on the
king side to threaten the black king he
plays F3 take away some Knight G4 jumps
Donya when is this board going to open
up we still have zero trades I really
feel like video should have tried to
prepare e65 you can get that move in and
White's position starts to crumble the
thing is magnus's Knights are incredibly
passive but I think vidit is going for
the more long-term strategy
of doing what exactly preparing Bishop
F6 and ultimately I think he is going to
prepare E5 there was a crazy tactic
there with Bishop take C5 and D4
trapping the queen that was insane
that was insane I was wondering why the
eval bar went crazy that is really nasty
look at this and I'm gonna I just I have
to show this Rook D5 and the Knight on
A6 finally has its moment in the Sun
finally has its moment in the sun in
terms of protecting the C7 Square the
queen is trapped and white basically
loses on the spot because once this Pawn
disappears your entire Center uh
essentially crumbles this doesn't help
by the way it's exactly uh the same type
of line I guess here the queen can go to
C7 uh but anyways black is winning in
the end let's go back to the live board
though we've got quite a few moves
radar is because before the Knight went
to F2 the queen had that spot but look
what vid is doing anyway he is just
moving forward now this is Pawn A2 which
is a long-term weakness it's essentially
both sides are up a pawn but in
different parts of the board
that's a great way to put it and vidit
continues to break apart White's control
of the center now The Rook 98 is sitting
pretty blacks control over the E4 square
is impressive and Magnus is again
struggling to create chances
on the other side of the board he's got
two seconds on his clock as well he's
losing look at fit it Go the E4 square
is Juicy just drop a knight in there
right now he does just that and C5 is an
opportunity as well for black or Bishop
C5 if you allow it and now Bishop takes
F5 snap that Knight off the board and
find a spot for your dark squid Bishop
on the long diagonal instead he's gone
Queen D7 he can take twice on F5 but
that would entail giving up the C6 Pawn
vid it down to eight seconds himself can
he keep his composure in time pressure
Magnus with 0.8 seconds
barely getting the moves off and that
King on G2 looks open but he finally
takes that Knight on that five this
looks great for video
and the moves are easy C4 is possible
but with three seconds on the clock I
wouldn't stir the pot he plays these
combos two seconds again F5 was missed
there winning the exchange all outside
scramble this black is all the controls
E4 take that thing he didn't take that
thing he didn't take it and he's allowed
Magnus to establish a pawn chain in the
king side and now the situation getting
more complicated oh my goodness now it's
completely pandemonium
but that F5 is loose and it was D3 what
a shot
he cuts the Queen off from the F5 square
and now he's safe
blacks up two Pawns
and this should be a technical win now
still not over though there's a pin
along the e-file that Vivid has to solve
and he solves it with a check but now
magnus's King is walking into the center
and it's still not over no it's not over
because black needs to get that King out
of there and how do you push your pawns
maybe you just gotta go through the king
side now
yeah King F6 walking out of the checks
and advancing his pawns I think you
called it Robert I think the right idea
is just to advance these pawns
methodically carefully without
blundering anything with all of his
pieces on dark squares there we go
that's it finally
Magnus succumbs and what a win to start
the three plus one segment two in a row
now for video Gujarati and he just take
took a bite of a much deserved snack as
now he is one two in a row the deficit
is just two points and Magnus he got out
played in that game did it really showed
some great technique
yeah and after Bishop F1 in the early
going I thought that Magnus was likely
to score a quick Victory but I think he
dropped the ball on the opportunity to
play A4 and by the time he realized what
had happened vidit had closed the queen
side had started operating in the center
and it was a dominant display by Vida
yeah there was some mess in the time
pressure but that's to be expected great
win confidence booster guess what it's a
two-point match
and look at this Knight E8 from Magnus
he's trying to trade the dark Square
Bishops and in this position if black
tries to get active with C5 you're left
with an isolated Pawn so don't I don't
know this very well I've never seen
really seen this Knight where you route
from E8 to D6 this early but I can't say
I dislike video position the slightest
it looks very healthy for him it looks
healthy and this is a very healthy plan
that has been around now for many many
decades you play F3 and then E4 and you
want to play this move very carefully
because the moment you play E4 you're
also weakening the D4 Pawn obviously you
can't play it now because the Knight
will hang so you have to kind of massage
your way around those problems with the
Queen's off the board who benefits
I think that white can just push forward
on the king side but that's why black
decides to strike against this Knight on
F4 if you have to go Knight back to E2
then black May throw more pawns forward
with F5 claiming much needed space on
that flank but if you take any six F
takes E6 black can play E5 the bishop on
D3 stares Into Thin Air and I prefer the
knights G5 is one of those moves you
look at it you know obviously you know
he's just chasing the Knight away but
there's actually a lot of nuance a lot
of positional depth that hides behind a
move like G5 knowing exactly when to
advance your pawns when white is
prepared to play E4 and beating him to
the punch is Magnus Carlson I think he
solves all of his problems and by move
20 he stands with a very comfortable
position in the end game video trying to
needle at him with H4 but I don't think
that there's all that much going for
white on the king side is there a knight
E4 check coming that white needs to be
careful about like just watch out your
king is enough too it's not gonna get
checkmated but it might fall into attack
no it's an absolutely a big problem for
white actually 94 check possible even
here
presumably Magnus is going to spend a
little bit of time calculating that
because if he can make it work then it's
definitely the move that you want to
play and I think he's going to play it I
think he's going to do it
you have to take this Knight if your
king moves you lose the Knight on G3 so
that's a a difference there but if you
take with the pawn then F takes is a
problem the bishop but this at first
glance looks good to me for black but he
goes Rook H5 Rook H1 so quickly then
maybe it's white who has the upper hand
upon closer inspection it's not entirely
clear which king gets caught under the
crossfire first black has to defend this
G5 Pawn now Magnus could play he takes
F3 and throw this in but he's not in
time to play this tactical move Bishop
G4 because G5 will fall with check it'll
fall with a fork and King G6 is going to
be met with the doubling on the age file
with tons of threads there are some made
threats there with Rook H7 as well let's
see how this plays out Magnus could also
push the pawn up to G4
but G4 is an F4 from White and that
Bishop on E6 that does not look like a
great piece it's just a kind of staring
into your own pawns the pawn D5 is
blunting your own Bishop suddenly I like
this position I just like the way he's
playing this match he has really been
able to right the ship yeah the
confidence that he's played with the
last couple of games has been awesome to
see he lost a couple of painful ones
earlier in the five and a portion it
hasn't impacted his confidence and his
Verve at all that's exactly what you
need to do against someone of magnus's
caliber as we see King G6 and Knight to
F7 as a stellar defensive move Uncorked
by Carlson he protects H6 and G5 and
prepares to uh simplify the situation
with Rook h8 which will really make the
king uh feel a little bit more
comfortable on G6 it's that filigree
Precision that you always like to
reference and magnus's average accuracy
level of 92.3 in the five plus one
section was the highest thus far and he
only has a two-point lead right now that
must be so frustrating for him he's
playing quite accurate chess but let's
not forget in that Bishop end game where
he had the draw in the bag he made one
slip with his bishop and suddenly did it
was able to win so accuracy if you're
not accurate until the very end it
doesn't actually help you secure even
more points well listen knowing Magnus
and and and having interviewed him as
many times as I and as we've interviewed
him he's probably exasperated right now
that this isn't a Blog he's exasperated
that the score you know isn't seven to
one or something like that but you gotta
tip your hat to Vivid he has played very
consistent brand of Chess yeah you know
he's missed some tactics here and there
but he's exploited the opportunities as
they've come and this is a pretty
important end game it's equal according
to the engine but I can see this going
in either player's favor the knights
look pretty strong but White's suffering
from some weaknesses here in the Sun on
the king side likeliest outcome
definitely still a draw
it looks like it and didn't might even
try to force it in the next couple moves
if their King goes back to F6 the Knight
goes back to E4 but maybe he'll play for
more with King E3 and say what is your
plan as black
I think the plan is to repeat moves
he hasn't done it yet but if he spends
all his time and gets in time trouble he
won't be able to win but he does the key
you're right good call Robert and I was
thinking he's adopting that old trick I
would use to convince my coaches that
accepting a draw was the right decision
oh but you know I ran out of time I had
only two minutes on my clock of course I
started with 45 minutes
but if you sit for 40 minutes you don't
have any time left so you might as well
take the draw and what do we have here
the Knight swings over to the queen side
using the entire board as a canvas but
Magna simply drops his King back I love
the placement of black snipe as it
guards the g-pawn as well as important
squares uh throughout the center
yeah because the D6 Square was one where
the white knight would have loved to
jump to and then to C8 now we see a swap
of pieces this looks like a draw for
sure I don't even see how either side
plays for a win you'd have to blunder a
full piece or you'd have to blunder a
transition into a pawning game like 96
actually threatens Knight F5 check and I
think black would be winning in that
pawn and because of the superior King
placement so vidit is the one who has to
be a little bit careful Magnus might try
for a couple moves before acquiescing to
the draw also I think it benefits him uh
given that he holds the lead in the
match
really good observation about the night
trade with the more active black king
that could have spelled disaster but now
the Knight just reroutes itself to C3 if
the Knight goes to H4 for black the
white king slides to E3 we could see a
repetition in that way as well
indeed we do
that is exactly what we're getting
Knight A7 to B5 Magnus he keeps it going
and I think he's keeping it going also
from the perspective of milking some
time off the clock exerting a little bit
of additional pressure wearing his
opponent down just a little bit more all
of those incremental moments they are
important when you add them up
and you can't win games that you've
already drawn and we know how many wins
Magnus has had from very equal positions
so why not look his King is active right
now but that night that was on F4 it it
wraps around a bit there was Knight C2
check that white had to be careful about
but A3 kicks the Knight back what's
happening I'd still be scared if I was
playing Magnus in fact I'd be scared for
either caller Knight C2 things suddenly
getting a little bit of tactical here
now probably still a draw after Knight
takes D5 but wait a second Knight takes
A3 and black gets this outside g-pawn
and I'm starting to get a little worried
for vivid he's got to be accurate now is
he gonna lose this how does he save this
the Jeep on so fast Oh What a fine 97.
oh leave the check
that was great by video right there not
over yet though night before another
accurate move and another one he's found
only moves to hold the game still not
over no no
two seconds he was Knight G2 and what's
not going to F4 only moves Knight H3 now
nope G2 losing black goes to death two
with the King
but Knight H3 and ig1 the Knight will
keep circling around and if black
promotes White's King will start to get
up to C5 and then it's a three result
game once again
and key up to D4 watch out where does
King Knight G5 Knight G5
oh he got that move off but barely but
Knight G5 wins oh my gosh deflecting the
knight from H3 it's a double X Glam and
it's a win for Magnus Carlson I cannot
believe but we just saw
on real but you called it that black
still had some winning chances and I
said and Magnus does you cannot win
games you've already drawn he won a game
that most people would have chalked up
to being just a draw it's never that
simple when Magnus is your opponent you
know people reported this while watching
Michael Jordan play basketball even
season ticket holders from the Bulls
kept marveling every time he took off
from the free throw line or put up a
50-point performance I've commentated
Magnus Carlson for most of my commentary
career but every time I see him winning
an end game like that it's unbelievable
in its own way because he's not playing
amateurs he's playing Amazing end game
players in their own right people who
themselves are capable of squeezing out
an equal end game against players like
nariditsky the fact that Magnus Carlson
does it to them is pretty insane
it's a much needed win too because it
had taken two straight games and then it
won an end game against Madness that was
crazy I agree with the feature chat
there this position look at this
completely symmetrical in nature in
terms of Pawn structure black can play
C6 and these are the types of positions
that Magnus plays for a win
oh absolutely and white slightly better
why exactly I don't know like sometimes
why is white slightly better maybe
because the Knight is incrementally
better placed maybe because the queen
has this window toward B3 it can tickle
some of Black's pawns black has a couple
of these very minor problems that have
to be solved I think you can solve them
by dropping the queen back specifically
to E7 and playing C6 well done but still
Magnus has the e-file and as long as he
holds the e-file he holds at least some
minuscule chances and maybe even C4 can
be considered
there's only one open line and White's
Rook controls it that said there are no
targets to go after and that's why
you're mentioning C4 that if you can
trade on C4 the bishop gets out there F7
feels quite vulnerable but C4 is one of
those moves that you can't take back
your D4 Pawn will be a clear Target so
I'm not sure if Magnus plays C4 here or
if he plays some kind of Rook E3 quiet
move but I don't think white can play
for win without your choice yeah with a
three-point lead in the match having won
the game that he just won I don't think
Magnus is going to take on uh any
unnecessary risk C4 doesn't strike me as
a particularly risky move because you
could liquidate in the future
uh by pushing the d-pawn up to D5 I can
guarantee you that that is exactly the
kind of wheels that are turning in
magnus's head right now he's
contemplating C4 he might resort to a
move like H3 or remove like Knight E5
given what we saw last game that would
not be tantamount to a draw for he is
still very much playing this position
for a win
yeah you can play C4 next and take with
a pawn rather than the bishop so he'll
have a hanging Pawn structure and open B
file to Target maybe Black's backward
Pawn so here Vidant plays Bishop to E4
Magnus Retreats attacking that bishop
and the bishop slides back to G6 I like
the way both players are handling this
Donna now it definitely feels like C4 is
uh quite a bit more appealing you called
it Robert his idea is to recapture width
upon maintaining the Integrity of his
Pawn structure what does he want what is
his next move well probably it's C takes
D5 and then bringing the Knight back
over to F3 and ultimately gaining uh
traction on this D5 Pawn
Bishop H5 is very tempting going after
that Knight on F3 but black needs to be
careful their back rank ideas because
the king doesn't have left so both sides
have this weakness D5 for black D4 for
white and Bishop H5 at the right moment
will probably be a good move White's
control over the e-file is quite an
annoying Factor the black has to deal
with it would be very nice if black
could just remove the Rooks from the
board not easy to do because the E8
square is undefended you could consider
a move like F6 but obviously move like
that comes with a pretty hefty price tag
and Magnus just starting to do Magnus
things here Bishop D3 is an excellent
counter-attacking move
he protected his Knight by attacking the
Black Knight Bishop takes F3 is met by
Bishop takes F5 and the e-file control
for white is great that's why the Knight
just slid back to D6 and queen C5 what a
Magnus choice that is such a Magnus move
right there it's vintage Magnus forcing
I think he's forcing an end game because
you do not want to give up D5
video will have to stick his 994 give up
upon and after the last game imagine the
nightmare of having to hold a pawn down
Rook end game against Magnus no he's
given up the pawn too much of a
nightmare well he wants a bit more of an
active defense instead of trading queens
and having to move the Knight away back
to the last rank or or giving the pawn
away in the center he says I'll give it
away but with more pieces on the board
taking on a three he wants queen C3 and
now B3 and D4 and E1 are all hanging
watch out for the third rank Bishop
takes H7 check but the queen is defended
by The Rook remarkably Queen Z1 guards
all three things at the same time
because you can't play Queen takes D4
because of uh the aforementioned Bishop
H7 Shaq of course there the queen is
undefended but queensy one is a little
bit passive Magnus could also choose to
give away the B3 pawn and put a rook on
D1 and then operate on the king side of
the move like H4 big big moment here oh
you can't even take the spawn because of
Bishop H7 so Rook D1 also serves the
purpose of protecting all three items
that are under fire
actually how does black respond to Rook
D1 You're simply going to be down to
pawn for the time being a G6 blunts the
bishop but creates loose squares in
front of the king so I think Rook D1 may
be the best try I love the move Rook D1
because it keeps the queen on its
optimal attacking Square Queen V1 is a
little bit passive Magnus though look at
how much time he's investing on this
move he's down to 30 seconds what is he
calculating he's calculating if I have
the black pieces well I'd be able to get
good sufficient counter play and maybe
win the game and that might be the
problems when your magazines you think
like Magnus but you have to recognize
that uh hey not everyone does he goes
Rook E3
whoa he's mad at himself
wait his idea is Queen takes B3 Bishop
takes H7 check but in that position you
can't take the queen because of back
rank mate you've got this check on H3
though with your queen things getting
super complicated as vidit takes the
majority of his own time to calculate
the thicket of variations Queen A1
that's impossible yeah Queen A1 Bishop
F1 Rook C1 which is barreling down the
first red but Queens you threatens a
counter back rank Checkmate on E8 that
is a much needed defense and didn't he
is down under
15 no 16 seconds now he made his move
but Magnus simply makes a Luft and this
is exactly the kind of position Magnus
wanted he's got a good Bishop against a
relatively bad Knight I think it's a
minuscule Advantage for white in a Time
scramble though Knights are very
valuable pieces so easy to miss some
sort of freak tactic or a fork let's see
how vid it handles this very important
time scramble we might get a queen trade
out of the draw but the way that these
previous time scrambles have gone I
think we're in for some adventures in
the sand game yeah why a draw look at
this position where the Knight on D6 now
is defended it goes back to PC that's a
great move I have this great move it
frees The Rook on the sixth Rank and
gets your knight active Rook C3 was
possible there instead he reroutes his
Knight to C5 Knight takes A4 does that
work no it doesn't because the bishop B5
and Brook C3 track them in King D2 so
great awareness from both players the
Knight goes back to E6 to check he'll go
back to C5 Maybe
Magnus advancing expanding on the king
side trying to deprive the night of key
retreating squares video going back and
forth but it seems like Magnus is
starting to make progress here on the
king side I'm looking for his clock he
barely is getting his moves up 0.7
seconds this is a bullet Scramble now
it's our trading pawns and done it let's
not forget the light score Bishop the h8
corner are not a match so vidit should
know his task
he does indeed Rook F7 check is magnus's
idea he's loading up a trebuchet on the
f file one second for Magnus point four
as he made his move and he's going to
bail out I think to a draw
yes he will he's gonna take B6 and H6
but it's going to be rook in one Pawn
versus rook in one pawn and just throw
away the a pawn put your king in front
of the H Pawn that is a draw
wow so we did get our share of
adventurous but I think a draw Fair
result
uh for a very balanced game
a good result for both players in that
one I thought that Vivint Health's very
steady I mean this is the thing about
the speeches Championship even when
you're facing a three-point deficit you
could still be proud of the way you're
playing I think did it is playing a very
very strong match uh Magnus Carlson a
year ago against 500 carwana he only
gave up four points that whole match so
the fact that that it's already there
and keeping this close it's showing that
video is in good form I remember that
match like it was yesterday I think we
can make the categorical statement that
to not get blown out uh in in an
increment match against Magnus Carlson
already means that you've basically
played uh to the best of your abilities
and that's very true here not only is he
not getting blown out he's very much in
this match all he needs is a win and
it's back to a two-point match so this
one gonna be a very important game going
into that midpoint break
and this position needs a midpoint break
we need to open up the center of the
board because it's very close and now it
took on D5 because the Knight on D7 is a
lousy piece the 99 C3 is much better the
pawn on D4 takes away both four jumps
from that D7 Knight
not gonna lie this is not the most
riveting position that I've seen today I
probably would prefer a night or if like
the one that they had in game two but
you take what you can get vidit gets his
Rook over to C1 notice that he brought
the F Rook over to C1 just to keep the
other rook in reserve on the queen side
Magnus initiates a bunch of Trades and
are we gonna get a substantive
transformation of the pawn structure no
vidit is going to keep the status quo by
moving the queen away from the pin and
leading to a bunch more trades
so it seems like did it okay to try and
make draws and one of the things that
you have to do in the SEC is play that
psychological battle does Magnus
actually want to make draws with vidit
the answer is probably no we saw their
head to head entering this matchup I
think we're like 12 wins for Magnus
three for visit and zero draws they do
not draw against one another so maybe
it's like come on let's let's put this
point here I'll steal some of your
rating points and it's not a bad result
for me
yeah this has been a just Ultra balanced
game but you can totally understand why
vidit is playing with an abundance of
caution every draw against Magnus
Carlson is an achievement uh in its own
right but
at some point you need to start coming
back in this match and maybe if it is
strategy Robert is to drag that drag
this match out to the bullet to keep it
at approximately a three-point lead
maybe he believes that his best chance
at a comeback is in the bullet segment I
don't know I mean we can ask of it
afterward but uh I think that he's been
playing really really well that last
game I think some people in the chat
were saying over 97 for both players
that essentially tells you all that you
need to know
well the shorter the type of show I do
think the chances go up for players who
are lower rated so I don't blame it if
that is his match strategy he does not
want to lose more games in this blitz
time Patrol and it's impossible and to
lose I was gonna say for white but then
I was gonna say we've seen Magnus win so
many impossible positions yeah we've
said that before
um it's impossible to lose against
anybody except Magnus Carlson is Magnus
Carlson going to try to unbalance the
game with E5 or is he just gonna keep
shuffling his Knight between C6 and E7
well he has no choice actually he can't
play E5
oh yeah because it's under control and
after Knight F4 you can't play E5
because the D5 Pawn is loose so we might
see this back and forth that will lead
us to the Midway point of this tide
Patrol a draw feels like a fair result
and didn't hasn't confirmed it there it
is
there it is indeed and we reach the
exact midpoint of the hour allotted to
the three plus one time control the lead
remains at three the match just kind of
hanging there in the balance this game
will be aborted I'm pretty sure uh
because we are at the halfway break
uh or not looks like yeah it hasn't been
uh stopped just yet but we are exactly
down the middle of the
60 Minutes allotted to this time segment
but hey if they play Let's commentate on
the game that's happening here by all
means I'm more than happy with the way
this game is unfolding especially
because they actually have an E4 opening
this time they have a bishops game
something relatively fresh uh so so
we'll keep watching as long as this game
doesn't get aborted
yeah this is a game well let's look at
this it feels like I'm in my childhood
and you love openings like this as well
where you just play a little bit of a
slower approach and you see that white
temporarily has the bishop pair and
maybe he's gonna keep the bishop here or
at least keep uh Bishop versus knight
quote unquote Edge what a weird sequence
of moves they're Knight A5 Knight A4
Knights on the rim are amazing clearly
as as our elders taught us the smoke has
cleared so much two pairs of minor
pieces has been exchanged I like what
Magnus has got in here he's got the
uncontested dark squid Bishop it could
come out to G5 at a moment's notice and
harass the night instead he takes the
positional approach and expands on the
queen side with B4 P5 Magnus playing
very adventurously to start this game
and that black knight just kicked around
it was an a fighter back to C6 now it's
the move again maybe Knight d8 to E6 I
feel like that's quite standard or as
you're pointing out Knight E7 to G6
they're two different options I liked it
on E6 because it takes away D4 at least
it makes it less appealing but it also
not an E6 closes down the e-file and the
Rooks don't get such open lines and to
that end after Knight G6 you could
potentially consider d65 of course given
that white is the one or the bishop that
could be counterproductive because if
you play it at the wrong moment you
allow white a free attack on the E5 Pawn
so maybe resisting that Temptation and
playing a slower move like Rook fe8 or
something relatively calm like H6 or
maybe even C6 to chip away at White's
Pawn chain I feel like that is more uh
congruent with the demands of the
position uh than you know a flashy But
ultimately flawed D5 which he's just
played I guess we'll see
maybe there is no flaw after all but the
E5 Pawn now becomes a Target at least
white can go after something but the
Rook can come to E8 so by putting the
Knight on G rather than E6 it allowed
black to strike in the center but wow
look at this move C4 he wants to kick
that Queen away and then Play Moves Like
Bishop B2 especially if the queen goes
to E6
great move again showing that concrete
considerations transcend general
principles there is a backward Pawn on
D3 but that Queen could not have dropped
back to D6 because of Bishop to A3 it
has to go back to this very awkward
Square now Magnus is very close to being
able to play D4 he can't quite do it yet
because C4 will fall maybe a calmer move
like Queen D2 should be considered but
vidit is heading for C5
and black could end up better here
Robert if white is not careful
if that pawn B6 was back on A7 then I
think white would be better but because
the pawn is doubled inherent to having
double pawns means open files the
semi-open a file hitting A4 is very
promising for black queen B4 becomes a
threat Knight C5 is on the agenda and H4
played by Magnus he does not care about
the A4 Pawn I just wanted to point out I
love the way that vidit maneuvered his
Queen first to E6 and then he did shift
it to D6 but only at the moment when
white moved the Rook away from A1 so
Bishop A3 is no longer a consideration
now it's time to bring the queen to its
optimal Square he reinforces the E5 pun
trying to take the sting out of the
subsequent movement of the h-bun I think
now he is ready to meet H5 with Knight
F4 and so maybe Magnus took the words
right out of my mouth considers G3 to
cover the F4 square and now H5 is much
more appealing
F6 was appealing for black because white
doesn't have a light Square Bishop if
that Bishop could go say out to A2
suddenly the light squares would be feel
vulnerable and Magnus strikes with D4 I
think that black can just trade I am
worried about this Pawn A4 that's such a
weakness
it's definitely a worrisome Pawn
especially in light of the Knight coming
to C5 big question here what is Magnus
gonna recapture with
if he takes to the bishop 96 seems
obvious I would not go for that if he
takes up the Knight on D4
maybe still Knight to E6 in this
position
if you can trade off a pair of knights
the Knight C5 becomes even stronger at
that point light will run out of options
when it comes down to defending that
pawn because Rook A1 obviously can
always be met with Rook A8 we do have
Knight takes D4
I do like 96 maybe Knight F5 there stirs
the pot a little bit more let's see what
Magnus comes up with here
the only thing I don't like for vivid is
that he's down under a minute he has had
some struggles so he did uh play well
under the rest of the time trouble in
some of the previous games as well but
Knight E6 play why does I get a question
mark did the email bar even change
once because it's not the eval bar it is
the evil bar and we already know that
it's very cruel I think very cruel for
vid it would be a well-timed H6 Magna
should really consider throwing that
movement to soften up some of these
Targets on the king side instead we do
see Knight F5 as I pointed out earlier
but after Knight C5 I honestly think
that the worst is behind him maybe H6
there I don't know
oh just trying to go after the black
king I like that and which Knight to C5
he chooses the E Knight and Dunya is
because H6 is not as powerful with the
Knight on D7 protecting the F6 Pawn
great observation that's exactly what
vidit had in mind he plays G6 Magnus
drops back to E3 but he is still hunting
and probing and chiseling and the Knight
is jumping over to D5 30 seconds for
both sides this is a very double-edged
end game once again
the Knight on D5 can I think
successfully be kicked by a pawn to C6
and also this A4 Pawn remains loose
black can swing that Rook over to A8
grab that A4 pawn and then try to take
control of some open lines I would be
worried if our Magnus especially look at
this clock he is down in time trouble he
doesn't see a move that he likes he goes
Knight D5 you're absolutely right C6 is
the immediate response vidit putting
pressure on the board on the clock five
seconds for Magnus where is he gonna go
back to E3 can vidit continue to
surround this Pawn with Rook A8 what is
the downside of rookie is there still
going to Rook DC or BC BC Rook D6 oh
I agree and he goes 95 instead
orchestrating a trade
of the bishop for the night
and then it doesn't take back yet that
is a sign of a super strong player and I
always compliment players in the news
they don't take right away he could have
preview he took with the F Pawn
isolating it because he wants that
initiative he gave his King some shelter
in the center and he's taken the pawn on
A4 simultaneously protecting B6 taking
this thing out of BC one second as
Magnus played King F3 he is now firmly
in the defensive activates his Rook 0.6
seconds as Magnus seeks counter play
against the pawn can he hold a draw here
he would be so fortunate the Black
Knight could come in D4 at any moment
but white might win King of the Hill and
stay in this game with the white king
going to E4 it goes back instead to G2
this is still uh Robert a three result
game if Magnus can go after the H Pawn
and he dies
but what's going on with this b-pod
which Pawn is getting there faster the H
Pawn Magnus is gonna win again and he
simply wins my resignation no he went on
time on time one time but he's winning
in the final position
wow Magnus Carlsen down a pawn but it's
not about the quantity it's about the
quality his H Pawn gets the other side
he leaps out of his chair and you see it
the Champions chest door chair there he
currently leads by Four Points it's been
a close match but it's nine to five in
minis's favor I can't believe the way
that he turns these games around but it
was in the driver's seat for the whole
end game Magnus makes three moves and
the pawn that seems most irrelevant the
most inconsequential Pawn on the whole
board right the Asian Pawn that ever
been forgot about that's precisely the
pawn which wins the game Magnus
reinforces his dominance he holds a
four-point lead and he's coasting he's
playing great he's taking care of
business it's a combative match it's a
competitive match Robert but right now
vidit needs to turn on at once again
even the sloppy games are still strong
ones for Magnus Carlsen he has a four
point lead the players will take a break
and so will we this is the speed test
Championship presented by coinbase it's
when we return
foreign
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four key notes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
end game we've added a new
classification called Miss for when a
move fails to take advantage of an
opportunity but it is otherwise a sound
move we've also changed the definition
of blunder now a move will only be
considered a blunder if it loses
material or allows a Checkmate coach
will now draw arrows and highlight
squares when you hover over or click on
the highlighted words in the move
explanation this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threats in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
[Music]
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase the
man you see in front of you is Magnus
Carlsen the world's top ranked player in
sporting that beach shirt that baseball
cap Donna he's also sporting a
four-point lead and he's also supporting
one equal end game after another that he
keeps on winning he's winning worse on
games he's winning better end games he's
winning equal end games he's winning all
sorts of end games and he's winning all
sorts of games and positions Magnus
Carlson just doing Magnus Carlson things
Robert
well his end game is to win this match
and the entire speed Chess Championship
so right now with the four point lead it
looks like Vivid Gujarat is in a tough
spot but we've been praising the play of
it even in that last game which he lost
he was up a pawn and if things had just
been a little bit different he could
have cut this lead instead of ballooning
up to four back down to two huge props
to visit it for the way that he's played
he's gotten a couple of great sparkling
victories that he can be proud of that
he can look upon after the match and
almost every game has been closed you
can't point to a single Magnus victory
that has been entirely one-sided they're
all coming down to the wire I mean this
last game was better for vetted all
throughout that end game somehow with
one second on the clock Magnus keeps
making perfect moves he keeps finding
the one way to generate winning chances
and these last 25 or so minutes of the
three plus one portion really really
pivotal like I always say Robert it's
not really realistic for video to wipe
out the entire four-point lead but if he
can get this down to or three he gives
himself a serious Fighting Chance in the
bullet where we know that anything can
happen
yeah the words Fighting Chance I think
those are essential because in the three
plus one it has felt like a true fight
right now Magnus Carlsen leads that time
control by score three to two he won the
initial time segment by scored six to
three but if that last game had gone a
bit differently it could have been a bit
of Gujarati who was leaving the time
frame there and that could have changed
the storyline but done it you're right
one game after another can't just focus
on let me quickly get four straight wins
you need to do it piece by piece you
need to do it piece by piece and you
need to make the most out of the white
pieces I'm curious what Vivid is going
to play in the next game we've seen D4
we've seen E4 by both players I think
this is not one of those SEC matches
where the openings truly decide the
course of the game but still I'm curious
to see what will be on the menu a French
will be on the menu and a guimard French
a very rare line where black develops
the Knight to C6 there was a famous
story uh so associated with this move uh
Reuben fine uh the American master was
annotating a collection of games from a
tournament in the 60s and he awarded
this move two question marks uh because
the grand Petrosian played it and uh
rumor has it to gun Patrol was not very
happy uh when he saw that particular
annotation it's actually not as bad of a
move as Ruben fly made it out to be
I know I stopped because
I knew you were gonna go with that the
position remains closed so black even
though you are unable to strike C7 to C5
to really get some control of the center
it's not the end of the world but it is
Pleasant for a video and one thing I
just want to quickly shout Donna which
may go unnoticed because of how quickly
the games are continuing video play E4
Vivid has Diversified his repertoire in
recent years and at the Tata steel India
rapid Blitz rajaba Vichy many people
were praising Viv as becoming a
different and improved player in these
last few years I would compare his
transformation to the to the one under
undergone by Anish giri uh also referred
to as anishkiri 2.0 that was inaugurated
with uh his performance at Tata steel a
couple of years back a lot of a lot of
similar components to that
transformation do for an openings
Diversified repertoire and a diversified
style more Universal that's how you
become closer to the world's Elite let's
see if that translates into more wins in
the three plus one segment we have kind
of a standard French structure at this
point it took Magnus a while but he was
finally able to get that Knight out of
the way and push C5
and once he does that he is going to
open up the sea file at the right moment
something you don't necessarily want to
do is take on D4 and see a knight
replaced upon there because the Knight
on D4 stares forward at the E6 pawn and
the B5 Square so Magnus closes it down
but Tanya when you close the center and
that side of the board white has a free
hand and you're showing a rook lift yeah
Reuben finds somewhere is kind of
smiling and saying maybe I had something
there was something to those two
question marks I assigned to that move
H5 typical idea freezing the G and H
pawns and allowing white to more
effectively maneuver The Rook to G3
which is exactly uh what vidit is doing
the other problem for black is that you
cannot easily Castle because you're
always dealing with a hanging Pawn on F7
if you play Rook f8 then after Rook G3
you're in even bigger trouble Rook G8
Robert can always be met with this very
nasty shot on H7 with a bishop
hold up can black Castle Queen side
because after Queen takes F7 there's a
rook well the bishop is no longer there
but there are sometimes you just chase
the queen around a bit maybe it wasn't
going to work out because uh White would
just steal too much now your king is
definitely not going Queen side at least
not yet ugh and now Knight H4 f4f5 video
going through the textbook plans here
he's also managing his time super well
he's up a minute on the clock
I think this is a big chance
and it's a big change because video is
now up on time and that's been the case
in some of these three plus one games in
the longer time controls it felt like he
was always down on the clock and Knight
to B3
did it ignores it done it not the first
game we've seen today with a harmless
night in enemy territory on that B3
square but that you know Knight on B
that's exactly right that night on B3
reminds me of when I was a little kid
um and my dad would give me a broken
computer to play with and I thought I
was doing all these things by pressing
all these buttons but the buttons would
actually do anything and that kind of
reminds me of Black's play on The Queen
side Knight B3 here's one button B5 and
a A5 and B4 there's another button but
White's play on the king side that's a
computer which actually works and if
white can quickly shoved the pawn
through to F5 if black skin gets
stranded in the center the game might be
over very very quickly I think Magnus
has to Castle Queen Side by hooker by
crook
and he has to do it now look at his
clock he's down to 25 seconds he's
spending way too much time
he doesn't know what to do I think he's
got a castle and he does
but he didn't find a satisfactory answer
to this idea of pushing F5 which Village
should do quickly and he does
takes it and Bishop F5 how about that
exactly you can't allow the black Bishop
there but he played Bishop F5 a rook can
come to F3 and then Knight on B3 it's
not participating the way it wants to
why can't you take twice on E6 and then
support the Knight if necessary with
Bishop C2 to F5
that looks very complicated though
because the bishop will be loose on F5
after Bishop takes H4 so you have to be
really careful here maybe Knight G6
right now Knight H4 to G6 and that way
you're hitting the rook and the bishop
and maybe you don't need to win material
you just continue to improve your
position move by move piece by piece and
I don't see a plan for black well piece
by piece is exactly how you do it Rook
H3 will swing over to F3 and I think you
called it white doesn't really need to
hurry I mean as I said earlier black
does eventually have this idea of b5a5
and B4 but that takes so much time look
at Magnus he sacrifices a piece and
that's a great practical idea Bishop
takes B2 he's gonna pick up a bunch of
Pawns and at the very least he's gonna
develop some Intrigue in this game
great decision I think it's the only try
he had where he felt like he had a
puncher's chance and you look at this
position two extra pawns for black but
an extra Knight for white but B5 A5 B4
those moves happen very quickly you need
to be careful if you're good God that
Bishop is like a cockroach you're trying
to kill well that cockroach just got
stepped on by Vivid flip-flops except
Magnus sacrificed it and tries to set
his Pawns in motion he's not fast enough
though that A7 Pawn is gonna disappear
and so is the queen after Rook A6
yeah this was not the best game for
Magnus I liked Bishop C1 but after that
it was very convincing from vidit so
those pawns they may look a bit scary
but white has what a queen and two minor
pieces for the two Rooks and how many
extra pieces do you need to beat Magnus
of course uh magnus's b-pawn and C Pawn
in the hands of anyone else would not be
intimidating at all when Magnus has
those pass pawns you're actually scared
I love the way that it is converting
this he sacrifices strategically one of
his minor pieces in order to bring the
other one in with tempo
E6 that's right the bishop is pinned oh
that's cool okay that's also really nice
The Rook is under attack the D7 Bishop
is loose
now he's 60.
you can also take the Rook but he wants
Bishop takes F5 and that is not as easy
okay this is still completely winning
the bishop simply blockades the pawns
and now E6 is still a threat The Rook is
also hanging somehow Magnus is still
alive
he's protecting his bishop and now Rook
C1 becomes an idea for black
is a good one the guy never dies
he never does Rook C1 again is on the
agenda but E7 is what white has but how
is it that it suddenly has to calculate
variations he's down to 10 seconds Rook
C1 is a threat then Rook takes B1 and
Rook D1 now wait a second Rook A1 Quincy
E7 E7 should finally do it rookie seven
and Bishop D3 Bishop B5 Queen takes B5
whoa whoa
92 rookie seven
oh my gosh rookie seven and white pieces
for a rook is there a Checkmate is there
gonna be a game over at any point here I
think that you can trade Queens probably
that's the simplest with three seconds
on the clock but can you even trade
queens and where does Black's King
escape to yes you can King you can force
them Bishop A6 trade tweets great call
by you and great execution from vidit
now he is easily winning I would think
but it's never easy when you're playing
it's Mac now Magnus is going to find
some sort of stalemate he's gonna tuck
his King over to H4 and he's gonna give
up his rook and it's suddenly gonna be
stalemate just watch uh this this is
well done though D7 and I think we're
not gonna get any kind of stalemate this
looks like game over
all credited he played amazingly he kept
his composure but how long did Magnus
survive in that game I would have
resigned that about 40 moves ago and I'm
on a late room wait wait wait you see
Magnus did it just one with the white
pieces and now vidit somehow was given
white again that is a mistake you see
Magnus recognizing it of course uh the
team is going to restart the game where
Magnus gets white time will be added to
the match clock but yeah look at Magnus
he's like what's going on here
hold on girl he's like no I want the
white pieces now great win by bit that
experiment in the guimard did not work
out for Magnus Carlson it was bad really
from the first moves they didn't knew
exactly how to respond to that sideline
yes vid it played an exceptional game he
broke through with that F4 F5 and that
has cut the lead back to three and we
saw the pre-match predictions Done Yet
everybody had Magnus Carlson winning 98
of people the smartest chest predictions
in 20 to 8 would be the final score that
still may be the case but it's not like
vidic got a few free points at the end
right now he is really keeping things
close he absolutely is and there's some
intermediate steps some hoops you have
to jump through if you want to score the
upset of the Millennium the first is
ensure that it's not a blowout so the
seeds of doubt and the seeds of
frustration into the mind of the
stronger player which I think vidit is
doing Magnus has shown a little bit of
frustration irritation perhaps uh with
some of the games that he's left on the
table and of course the second step is
to make sure that you stay within three
or preferably even two or one going into
the bullet segment
okay well vidit is within three at the
moment we do have a London system
out of the gates in this game and Magnus
keeps going back to this so he likes the
London it was played in the world
championship match that he did not take
part in and dingley ran against Jana
pamachi but when you look at this this
queen V3 stuff again what do you make of
this and whose position would you rather
have yeah this is a bit of a sterile
line it's a line in which
it's hard to say which side plays where
like on the one hand sometimes white
plays B3 but if blackstroke is unseeed
then you don't want to play B3 both
sides can play in the center like white
can prepare E4 black and prepare E5 so
I'll be honest I don't really understand
these types of positions I don't know
exactly who's playing for the advantage
as a kid I would probably choose black
because of the space advantage on the
queen side but the computer always seems
to assign a slight Edge to White here
I'm sorry I got distracted by the
feature chat there's only one player who
is better than Magnuson and games and
that is table pace so that's the famous
grand master John table base
that was a really good one so in this
position we don't have an end game in
fact we've had zero pieces traded it's
all locked up here white may try to go
for E4 especially if the Rook E1 and
black may play for B4 but you can't play
Rook B8 that's the one thing holding
black back is that Bishop on F4 is a
nuisance and you don't want to play B4
prematurely that walks into the very
thematic tactic Knight D takes C4 and
the Knight on C6 is loose and that is
exactly what Carlson is trying to set up
vid it says I wasn't born yesterday he
goes A6 leading to our first trade of
the game on move 17.
and the bishop slides up to E5 we may
see the dark Square bishops come off the
board but Bishop takes F6 followed by E4
that's one of the key ideas for white
and for vidit the question is do you
plug the square with your own Knight I
think you can also try to jump the gun
here well in a good way with Bishop D3
um and the point is that after Bishop F6
Bishop F6 E4 doesn't come with Tempo
anymore so you would have had time to
play E6 but Vida doesn't seem to care he
allows Bishop takes F6 and
I don't see any other ideas any other
active ideas for Magnus other than to
trade on F6 so whether it's good or bad
you kind of have to do it I think
and I think after Bishop F6 Bishop F6 E4
he won't take on e4 many of us would be
tempted we're about to see this happen I
think after E4 is played Black will play
Bishop to E6 back to defend the D5 Pawn
in that way and say you're gonna trade
on my terms if he wants to take on e4
then probably he should recapture on F6
with the queen that seems to be a better
version of D take C4 he could still play
Bishop E6 no he does take on e4 and will
we get no we will not get a knight
versus Bishop situation we will get a
bishop pair for black I like magnus's
position though I think he's slightly
better now
he is because he's got control over the
a file he has a knight compared to that
Bishop on G7 which is staring into a
brick wall and Rook C7 was played I
probably wouldn't trade pieces if I'm
Magnus I like bringing the Rook back
somewhere oh there's Queen A1 he's
training on his own terms but is the
queen on A7
really all that worthwhile
hmm well David says no but why not it
looks pretty good for white because the
bishop and E4 covers that A8 Square
I really I really like Bishop F6 it over
protects the E7 Pawn so that the other
Bishop could move and then the queen
could potentially dive into F4
King G7 another great prophylactic move
bringing the king to a safer spot moving
it away from the eighth rank is Magnus
setting up for Rook A6 here
and what is his response then to Queen
F4
oh Queen F4 with the bishop hang on e4
PC one check it might lead to a
repetition but also some big problems
for white and is black going to play G5
G4 that's a big question if you go on
the offensive it feels like Magnus has
gone astray in the last couple of moves
I think he put too much stock into his
Queen side play but there's nothing to
attack on that side of the board there's
nothing on the a file so when you play
Rook A6 and your pieces get stranded and
gummied up on the queen side like that
your king starts to experience major
discomfort really like the way that
vidit has set up his pieces on the king
side his King feels really impervious uh
surrounded by his faithful Bodyguard the
F6 Bishop
to get after that king queen of four
looks quite natural but maybe Magnus has
Bishop C6 planned where he trades the
light Square Bishops and that's what
it's concerned about the B5 Pawn will be
loose the bishop on F6 looks worse than
that and I don't have three so I wonder
if did it will go forward with Queen to
F4 I would not trade Queens that's for
sure but what else is there great call
and that's definitely the reason he
stepped back to C7 to keep the C6 Square
protected now don't go back to D6 and
blunder The Rook that's an easy blunder
to make Queen C8 might allow Knight E5
and so vidit decides to change up the
nature of the position
to what I'm sure is magnus's great
relief now he no longer has to worry
about the safety of his own King and
once again it feels like White's
position might be a little bit
preferable and look at this G3 Magnus is
trying to provoke vidit into taking that
pawn and losing B5 then it says no thank
you I need to keep that pawn he can play
Rook B8 in the near future play for B4
at the right moment but as soon as you
play B4 that C4 Pawn is loose and that
Knight is jumping around like a fish out
of water except it's quite a bit more
dangerous uh than a fish out of water it
feels right at home in fact in this type
of position where you can chisel away at
some of Black's weaknesses but look at
Vivid expanding on the king side maybe
bringing his King up toward the center
20 seconds on the clock that's my
greatest concern for vivid is his clock
situation
and he was F4 so wow Rook A7 is a pin on
the seventh rank the king escapes that
when the case in the center now I feel
like vidit has accomplished something
okay but so has Magnus in terms of
centralizing his Knight things getting
very tactical Bishop C1 tying itself
down to the bottom B2 does Magnus calmly
play B3 or does he seek tactical
complications with Bishop E6
3 yeah Bishop E6 is the type of movie
you want to play but it actually doesn't
carry any sort of huge threat so B3
seems to offer a trade then after the
swap Bishop B2 for black anyway C3 is
loose I feel like vidit is handling this
very well that under 20 second that is
the thing that is worrisome Bishop to C6
which is essentially the same as Bishop
to E6 we might get a trade on D7 and
Knight takes B5 and that I think likely
will lead to a draw
it should and we see a swap Rook to B8
now I mean Rook D5 he was the more
active move great call everything's
coming off the board yep we're gonna get
liquidation
and Magnus has to find suitable
arrangements for his Knight but that
night has plenty of squares
it's essentially a dead draw once this
Knight evacuates back to White side of
the board which it just did
and G3 he's just he's gonna take it no
he's too smart for that because you
could take it and that's a theoretical
draw but that also will waste a lot of
time off the match clock and a big
question for you Donya is does vidit
want another 3-1 game or would he rather
get straight to the bullet
I think he would rather get straight to
the bullet I I don't know it feels like
Magnus has been really at home in this
game
and I think Magnus is the one uh who
wants as most as many three plus one
games as possible because bullet Robert
bullet is very unpredictable you just
never know how it's going to go you
could be the greatest bullet player in
the world and something could go wrong
on that particular day I think Magnus
wants to build up the maximum cushion
going into the bullet uh which is
I don't know maybe not he's shuffling
his pieces back and forth
just gonna see that draw but the 50 move
rule I imagine unless he plays G5 that's
the only way to avoid the draw but then
the black Bishop will take that pawn
when he gets there so uh this is a time
wasting strategy from Magnus it's
perfectly acceptable it's part of the
rules and we've seen players like Hikaru
use it to their advantage so why not
Magnus and now did it gets the white
pieces done this is probably the final
Blitz game of the match if vidy can win
this he'll only be down by two points
and he will have a legitimate shot at
the world number one huge game just
think about the the difference between a
four-point match and a two-point match
it's night and day can visit step up to
the plate he's got the white pieces he's
got Rie Lopez that he's felt comfortable
and increasingly comfortable in the last
couple of years let's see what he can
bring to the table against one of the
Premier experts from the black side in
Magnus Carlson
and look at this position there's an
open a file so White's Rook on the queen
side is probably the best piece on the
board at least relative to its
counterpart but black plays the solid
you have an open file so what what are
you going to attack over there I think
that white needs to trade a few pieces
we see the start of that with that
Knight to D5 but done that this reminds
me of a certain world championship match
not ding versus nepo but Magnus versus
nepo yeah I don't remember that match
very who won that match was it nepo
yeah it's kind of hazy in my mind but
look at just the the Comfort level that
Magnus is displaying in all of these
real Lopez structure he knows exactly
where the pieces belong when they should
get there and I already think that he
solved most of his opening problems Vita
trying to Institute some more problems
with D4 and we're going to get something
really tactical here as Magnus
immediately trades on D4 what do you
make of this committal decision and how
is white going to recapture if you take
with the pawn black plays C5 and this is
I think what we're about to see where
now black can claim I'm up a Pawn on the
queen side you're up upon as white in
the center and this is why I try to
avoid saying it's even material I think
that doesn't explain things very well
but black has mobile pawns on the queen
side white has stuck Pawn in the center
and I've harped on this before but this
is once again kind of like a benoni
structure you get this out of a modern
benoni and a lot of uh the evaluation in
such position hinges on who controls the
five score who controls you know this
dark color complex along the line that
answer is very very clear it is clearly
Magnus Carlson he's aiming at B2 is
Knight can jump to F4 or to E5 and the
bishop on f8 later on in the game can
join Society via E7 and F6 once the
queen moves of course I really like the
way Magnus is handling this
if white plays Queen C2 at some point
Bishop takes H3 is also available so oh
yeah you have to be careful in all
directions B3 was a smart move that Palm
was under attack you could place a
bishop on C4 at the right moment to
stabilize now I think that white should
play Bishop C4 and say well what
weaknesses do I really have but this
bishop B7 Bishop F6 maneuver it's now
become a a reality uh and perhaps even
an immediate reality uh as Magnus tries
to find a way to rest control of the a
file from White right if white trades on
a which he just did that's a major major
concession that video has just made for
free and he is trying to cover all of
the important infiltration squares down
the A1 but look at Magnus clamping down
on the F4 score preparing defianchetto
his Bishop he is completely in command
of this game right now
that rules definitely deserve that
exclamation point because you're
pointing out Bishop E7 to F6 he says
I'll go to the same diagonal but let me
take control of the F4 Square so is
white going to be able to play F4 I
don't think it's so easy Bishop G7 F4
there's always a queen D4 check to throw
in either white king also gets in some
danger and the open a file is clearly a
good thing for black
absolutely and that is why vidit Taps
into his only active resource that is
the move f2f4 which he is trying to
shove through even in the face
even in the face of Black's clamp F4
will open up the f file I think Vivid is
doing everything he has to do to
generate active counterfeit but look at
Magnus shutting down the king side in
Comes The Rook in so many different
lines Wright's position is on the cusp
of total collapse
it was such a calm start to the game and
now White's King looks a bit open that
Bishop on G4 it is kind of in danger of
being trapped in some positions but
white doesn't have another Pawn to
attack it with like if you put F5 for
white you give up the dark squares but
you trap that Bishop in there you just
don't have a pawn going to H3 after that
that's a great point that would have
made all the difference the presence of
H3 G4 would have made it a very
dangerous idea indeed and this is where
vidit I think is going to pay the price
for giving up the a file I think it's a
perfect opportunity to involve The Rook
via A1 pinning the bishop to the other
rook and creating threats on all sides
of the board of course technically white
could move the bishop in response to
that but man oh Rook A2 whoa no he
didn't second that is the exchange
that is sick he gives him his Rook for
the bishop because the bishop protects
so many important pawns and squares wow
what a fine by Magnus there can I say
that is sexy and it is also the best
move because the Rook is hanging the
pawn Falls the other Pawn Falls and the
white king is gonna get caught in a
massive attack orchestrated by all of
Black's pieces put together I would just
grab E4 and enjoy my life here if I'm
Magnus Carlson
how easy is this position because the
eval bar is saying that black is clearly
for choice
but what's the follow-up it is right now
a bishop and one Pawn for Rook even if
you steal that second Pawn as he did
this doesn't seem straightforward man if
I had this position against Magnus with
white in a classical game I might have
had to hit the bar after the game it
just feels like there's no hope for
white because B3 is also likely to fall
Vivid clinging to that pawn with all
that he has left rookie three is
actually a great move because the Rook
can also swing over to G3 and that is
the way in which white Engineers some
counter play that King on H7 not feeling
too comfortable and look at vidit
forcing this bishop away so that the
queen can try to infiltrate via E8 not
over yet
and if that Queen gets to the last rank
sudden the black king is in huge trouble
but after Queen A2 he goes right back he
wants to keep the B3 Pawn defendant I
think that's much needed in this
position because you can't allow Black's
pawns to start running off the board now
obviously black has a draw in his pocket
that's not the question right there's
Queen D1 Queen H5 there's Queen E4
anything draws how does black nail the
final nail on the coffin here in terms
of getting to this B3 Pawn or getting to
White's King maybe a move like H5 maybe
covering the G file with Bishop G6 but
those are pretty hard moves to play
because they're kind of amorphous and
Magnus investing most of his time
Advantage into calculating C4 here we go
he gave away most of his objective
Advantage as well but he wants to push
his past Pawn but white goes Queen eight
and watch out for Queen G8 Checkmate but
don't go Queen A7 he plays the right
move it's the only good Square for the
queen
there's a draw in magnus's pocket but
will he go Bishop G6 and take the plunge
no the bishop is saying three yeah we
both think he might have forgot about
that and then there's B2 so that does
keep the position very interesting but
the is the white work even able to stop
that pawn because Rook B3 walks into a
fork on D1 I would play Bishop G6 here I
don't see a move for a while but there's
Bishop D4 at the end of that variation I
think
what is happening he does get a queen
but now it's an extra Pawn for black but
opposite colored Bishops that should
leave white in a position where you can
draw but don't play Bishop D4 now
because Queen F4 check I was gonna say
still a little bit of work to do for
vivit but he has done that work and he
has held the draw a huge result for a
bit at improbable and Magnus exasperated
there despite the brilliant exchange
sacrifice despite the heroics in the
opening he can't pull out the win and he
will have to satisfy himself with a
three-point lead going into the bullet
this Robert is a close match
it is indeed three points separate these
two and Magnus he expects the most from
himself he did probably expect that
Vivid would be a fighter but ten to
seven I don't think our community could
have expected this this going into the
bullet really gives vidit a legitimate
shot yeah Adidas playing out of his mind
yes he's down three points against
Magnus but the fact that he's in this
match going into the bullet the fact
that he has as I put it at the start of
this segment a Fighting Chance tells you
all you need to know about the kind of
effort uh and the kind of resilience
that we have seen from Vida today can he
cap off an incredible comeback in the
bullet or will Magnus continue to do
Magnus things well I guess there's only
one way to find out isn't there there is
but the players they'll get a much
needed break before the action continues
will do the same but before we get to
outbreak I want to give a shout out to a
G1 because ag-1 is a new partner of the
SCC it is your daily support of key
Health functions from mental performance
to energy and the immune system it's the
one product that does the work of many
to find out more visit
drinkag1.com chess or use the command
8g1 in chat thank you to ag1 for
sponsoring the SEC thank you to ag-1 for
putting Danny wrench on the graphic
thank you everyone for watching we will
take this break along with the players
but when returned it's more from this
matchup and speech's future presented by
coinbase
[Music]
thank you
chess kit is fine chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chest puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
did you know you can add Emoji to your
online games and Analysis boards simply
click on the Emoji palette icon select
your emoji and left click on the board
you can choose from a host of notations
animations emoticons and even your
favorite chess personalities
emoticons it will fade away after a few
seconds
however notations and special animations
remain on the board until they are
cleared to clear them simply left click
on the Emoji or hit the clear all button
at the bottom of the palette
fun try them all on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
we are back at the speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase we
are watching none other than world
number one Magnus Carlsen playing his
match but his opponent Danya didn't
Gujarati is giving him all that he can
handle
absolutely major major props to visit
really from move one of game one he has
put his heart on the line in this match
Magnus has been doing Magnus things he's
won a couple of sparkling end games I
don't want to overthink it Robert I
think the best way to categorize this
match is just a bunch of really high
level chess
it has it from both sides did it he is
unleashing his potential against the top
rated player in the world but Magnus
Carlsen is number one for a reason he
has won so many events he's actually won
four of his previous five events heading
into this competition the only event he
didn't win was a second place finish in
the bullet Chess Championship Hikaru of
course won that one now vidit not as
experienced of a bullet player as Magnus
has been in recent years with all of his
bullet brawls and all of his long bullet
matches but but it's not bad he's fast
he's tactically sharp and he has a lot
of experience in time scramble so do not
count out uh the Indian Talent do not
count vid it out especially with the way
that he's been playing we're underway
with a grunfeld slav and one of the most
boring openings in all of Chess Robert
it really is and you see both sides
bring their Knights into the center but
the pawn structure has changed earlier
you asked me I actually think that was
in the max team against good cash match
but I'm losing track of things it's a
double header whose Pawn structure do I
typically favor this is now symmetrical
both Bishops are staring down the B file
so no roofs can join the party
Donna what's the plan here
well it's very uncomfortable for both
sides because neither side could put a
rook on B8 and you're just itching
you're just itching to combine the rook
and the queen I think black's plan was
maybe to orchestrate C5 but Magnus beats
him to the punch and look at the clock
situation in the early going Carlson has
managed to locate a position that he's
just a lot more comfortable with and
he's already up 30 seconds and he also
has a better position as the pressure on
D5 reaches an apex and forces vidit to
retract his Queen to its initial square
but that's a great move from video it is
because C5 is a lot less tempting if it
doesn't come with Tempo and then black
and strike with E5 at the right moment
so look at this G5 was an idea that
Bishop 104 was running out of squares
great awareness for Magnus himself I've
noticed that in recent months Magnus has
accelerated the pace of his bullet play
we noticed this in the bullet Chess
Championship he plays really really fast
even with the increment and that's an
incredible way to put serious pressure
on his opponent 49 seconds and E4 blast
through the center creates massive
pressure on the E5 Pawn of course he
sees it he is a beast in bullet
but it doesn't actually win material so
I'm not a little bit surprised that the
evaluation is so high five yeah F5 and
E4 and that D4 Pawn is a problem oh
apparently there was an exchange stock
on E5 that Magnus could have explored
but instead he is exploring a queen
trade and forcing a queen trade
he does and he's gonna get it
uh-oh Donnie this looks really good for
Magnus it's the fact that black can't
put a rook on ba this is killer it's
killer because now Magnus is going to
grab the B file
and there's nothing that Vida can do
about it he grabs the B file the sixth
Rank and past C Pawn what does exactly
this black have in return pawns all them
light squares ugh Rook B5 it's so easy
to play this in bullet A4 really any
move improves your position this is dead
lost for pervaded unfortunately
uh game one is very one-sided and it
makes sense for vinna to play this on
but in the upcoming games if he's a lost
position he might need to resign right
away to give himself a chance to come
back in the match yeah I agree I agree
completely this is not resignable just
yet but if Magnus makes a couple more
accurate moves you can consider there
was a devilish strap set by Vivid there
Rook takes D5 King E6 would have trapped
The Rook but obviously Magnus uh he sees
such things in his sleep
and now it's time to start thinking
about resigning I think
unfortunately the white Rook is too
powerful I mean the a-pawn can start
pushing up there it goes and black
doesn't even get F4 you want to spring
for your pass point of your own you're
not oh
the most debilitating thing Magna still
has 32 seconds he has a full complement
of half his time he doesn't need any of
it he's playing instantly he's playing
powerfully and Robert we could confuse
this for a five plus one game such was
the level that Magnus just played in
that end game he's the only person in
the world who can display such a Level
Playing instantly the entire game
it looks like a classical game for what
it's worth it was very high quality no
mistakes really from Magnus he didn't
sacrifice that exchange on E5 which he
may have done in a classical game but he
played with exquisite technique and this
is a forcing variation down in your
King's Indian expert do you like this
line for white or black I think white is
slightly better objectively but in a
bullet game very very easy to play with
black you've got a lot of low-hanging
fruit kind of moves you could get the
Rook to d8 the other Rook to E8 of
course the biggest thing to watch out
for as black is the health and safety of
your D6 Pawn if you give that pawn away
your position collapses Magnus has
absolutely no intentions of giving that
pawn away
and he just starts trying to trade off
Knights and now the knights are off the
board uh black doesn't really have this
D6 spawn to worry about especially the
king gets to f8 and E7 but that would be
easier said in a queenless position
Baroque takes D6 is possible here but
then Magnus would give away his Queen
for two Rooks and get Monopoly over the
D file that does not look appetizing in
the least great job by vidit creating
some pressure on the king of look at
magaz Rook A6 Rook V6 the the just the
deafness the adroitness with which he
handles his heavy pieces it's crazy man
Rook B2 is coming suddenly Magnus is
better
yeah Rook B2 doesn't work right yet
Queen came to stop it but the Rook came
to C8 which wasn't the engine's
recommendation and look at video playing
King F2 going into the pin and up the
board
one move on the queen side is followed
by one move on the king side for Magnus
as he freezes the progress of White's
age Pawn but how does he improve his
position Rook B2 has to be calculated
carefully instead he plays King H7 kind
of biting his time preventing a
potential Queen Sally to H6 vidit is in
trouble once again
Rook four to D3 can you just go after
the A3 Pawn try to trade queens and uh
this doesn't look so bad for white
anymore I didn't see that move at all I
stand corrected probably closer to equal
if anything
how do you even take back you take with
the d-pawn white controls the open file
there we'll put a rook on B3 Rook B3
right now don't like d takes C5 I
thought Rook takes C5 was basically an
immediate draw Robert because White had
no good way to defend C4 now now it
feels like it's white who's pressing for
the advantage
take B7 first
dude it does wow if it can get this win
it's back to three and then it's trying
to show him that I can hang with you in
bullet chess
but he's gotta continue playing
accurately and Magnus is activating his
Rook it's gonna get scary Robert with
the Rooks the piggies coming to the
second rank Magnus is probably going to
recover at least one pawn and he's gonna
have practical drawing chances here good
ones at that
oh those Rooks are on the second right
there G2 Falls H4 could fall in the near
future and many of White's pawns are
gone but is that c Pawn quick enough
push him baby Rock'em Cowboy C5 coming
Rook a seven block hating from C7 Magnus
Bishop C8 no pasaran but can visit nail
in the coffin here does he get his King
up to D4 what's the right approach
he might try to Rook B8 and Rook takes
C8 if he gets C7 in time but I think the
black Rook would slide back through H1
and now it's both players I mean look at
this game white has chance of the more
advanced pass Pawn but black can go
after the white king Magnus is going to
win this game it feels like vidit is
faltered he's brought his King all the
way back to its most passive Square
everything back I think vid it's
fighting for a draw now
he is but at least he has stabilized all
of his pieces defend one another and the
white king can sit safely on H2
o Pawns
oh watch out for Rook D2 coming if you
move your Rook on the C file King F2
bit it holding on he's playing Super
accurately to hold on Magnus could throw
in H3 but he's saving that move for a
rainy day
whoa vid is down
oh he's barely getting his moves off
gosh and that pawn is still stuck King
G2 Gotta Move now he fled
he Flags he needs his King over on G2
but Donna he couldn't move his Mouse in
time
oh man what a heartbreaker what a great
positional game by Vida to start that
ending and then suddenly snap of a
finger I can't snap but if I could I'd
make the snapping noise just to
symbolize how quickly Magnus is able to
turn these end games around he plays
worse end games for a win and he is the
only player in the universe who does
that with total regularity across all
time controls
he's incredible and he is now Up by Five
Points Vidant has been incredible in
this match but in those key moments down
the stretch it has felt like Magnus was
just a little bit more accurate and a
little bit I don't want to say hungrier
because both players want to win but
there's something about Magnus where
he's ready to pounce no matter the
position
no completely and and this is a
watershed moment in the match there's
still 20 plus minutes left in the match
this match is not over you've got five
games to play but you have to start
winning right now and you have to start
taking serious risks but calculated
risks and I think he is
wow this is looking good for video this
is the type of Chess that I think did it
fans wanted him to hold way through
don't be afraid of your opponent play
the position what is this is a drawback
it's a draw and this is a classic
technique but a double exclaim in a
bullet game
should I show this I guess we'll wait
for a minute to execute those moves he
can sack his Queen on B3 or an A1
oh if he Stacks his Queen on A1 we have
a game there I think finish should go
for that he absolutely has to go for it
you can't really afford a draw at this
point particularly if you've managed to
get a double-edged position but it's
much easier for me to say in the comfort
of my warm office than again than
against Magnus Carlson
it's true we don't have to play down a
queen for some material but did it he
makes the draw he wants the white pieces
and he trades Queens so this variation
is all the rage but Donna is it a good
bullet opening
I think it's okay I mean if you know all
of the typical ideas for white if you
know exactly where the pieces belong I
think that white can play this in bullet
I'm a little bit worried though because
Magnus knows absolutely everything and
this G5 G4 idea I think is recommended
by Erwin lemie uh in his uh chessable
course on the chorus Magnus clearly
showing that he's done his homework here
Magnus looking at chess games who would
have thought it if you ever watched the
uh documentary on Magnus he devours all
material on the game of chess and sort
of shows based on his skill set but look
at this just bring your knight to F4
controlling these dark squares what does
white have in this position as black
will of course play H5
nothing Knight G2 whoa
that's such a good move you want your
page six
wow
incredible this is just this is
positional Mastery in a bullet gaming
this is unprecedented the way and the
way that Magnus is improved you know if
you look at his bullet performances over
the last couple of years how much faster
he's gotten how much crisper at bullet
tactics it's insane
he's threatening Checkmate right if the
bishop moves and a rook gets the d8 god
the white King has no moves that's
vulgar
get that out of the commentary we've got
kids watching wait you can play it
anyway
well Bishop V6 the Knight can take
that's the good news because it covers
the d8 square but then how are you gonna
cover it doesn't matter and if Knight
takes B7 you just go Rook V8 but Magnus
going very very positional here can't
really blame him he wants to play with
an abundance of caution he's still much
better because of his Monopoly over the
dark squares all over the board
this looks great Bishop here open space
that Knight on C3 completely dominated
by that pawn on C6 I think that it's you
know nice to play Bishop E6 when you're
a competator but it would have shattered
Black's Pawn structure whereas this
position there is no harm and everything
is looking good for magnets his piece is
operating in concert like a practice
Philharmonic
uh Symphony it's crazy every piece
fulfilling its own roll Rook G2
apparently wins the game with a
beautiful sequence of Bishop checks he's
gonna find it you know it you know it no
he doesn't
still winning not not that easy to spot
in a bullet game but this looks great
for black you're just trying to weaken
to loosen the pawn chain and go after
the base pawn and what we take for
granted so often are magnus's play is I
really like to draw attention to how he
plays on both sides of the board it's it
it produces an aesthetic effect even to
someone who barely knows the rules of
the game look at how one move is on the
queen side then the other on the king's
side then they gather in the center he
uses the board as his canvas to produce
beautiful paintings whether it's bullet
or Blitz or classical and look at this
Checkmate on G4
that is sick
amazing game
and you were being so descriptive I felt
like I was watching that be painted and
that final move that final position it's
a photo finish it's picturesque it's
another win for Magnus Carlson Diego
Velasquez would be proud of that one
that belongs right in The Prado Museum
Magnus has got to be proud of that game
no you were doing so well until you
threw in that pun chat come on get
involved what do you think of Dinah's
pun there be honest let him know but Don
I mean that game was seriously awesome I
think Chad is enjoying that I mean it's
just such a beautiful thing to have a
Checkmate stem from an attack like that
every move consecutive every move part
of a larger strategy and it all ends in
a Checkmate in the end game
just a treat to watch that
everybody except for video Gujarati who
has seen a three-point match it's all
the way up to six it has doubled that
Advantage from Magnus Carlson and here
in this game once again black is solid
did it has nothing that he should worry
about but Magnus makes you worry just by
sitting across from you or playing
against you on the internet exactly it
doesn't matter if it's a symmetrical
structure doesn't matter if there are no
pieces on the board he will always find
a way to stir the pot and he's still got
a little bit of work to do there's 16
minutes remaining in the match he's got
a six point lead on the scoreboard one
more win would essentially seal it
not giving up hope let's see if he can
get on the board with at least a draw in
this game
and this position it does look very
solid for black no weaknesses that I can
see exploited but Madness wants some
kind of G5 Knight G4 checkmating idea
he's going for the attack
his form is honestly unbelievable
but worth two from here Rook dhek he has
to be careful not to overextend himself
on the king side as he goes after that
it's a pawn that pawn cannot be easily
defended and so vidit counter-attacking
some of White's vulnerable pawns on the
king side great job by vidit seeking
active counter play
and he's gonna win the A2 Pawn first but
okay but now very um
it might be necessary or he's gonna
force a draw if white keeps going back
to A7 but what mango should do is make a
two-time repetition and before he makes
his third time just waste all of his
remaining clock
before he gets a chance to do that it is
vivid who insists on playing for a win I
feel like that's a bit unadvisable given
how passive he is Magnus can start
repeating again but now Magnus says hey
you don't want it okay I'm gonna play
oh
oh no the Black Knight can't move at all
and there's F5 ideas Knight takes E7 and
F6 Magnus could have flirted with the
idea of getting the king over to C5 if
his King was on D4 in this position it
would have been winning but practically
this is still so hard for black to play
King F6 and it's all over again another
equal end game pulled out by Magnus
Carlson
did its pieces could not move and when
they did it allowed the white king into
the position video you could see him
disheartened there white is going to win
that's another victory for Magnus
Carlson and you feel forbidden this is
just epic form that's being displayed by
Magnus vitted is not doing anything
egregious he's not making any big
mistakes in these games he's getting
outplayed from start to finish
and I do want him to score at least one
victory in the bullet but the way Magnus
is playing right now he's not coming
close
when Magnus is on form like this it's
hard to take him down and magnus's
bullet rating I can see it it's up to
33.61 that's ridiculous that is totally
ridiculous and Magnus just following up
on the form that he just played in the
bullet Chess Championship
he's incredible
wow and we are gonna get more games in
the second year but the players uh you
see oh did it lose connection because
his camera is now gone that might be the
issue and well it doesn't change the
match score it doesn't change the
trajectory of this match it's been all
Magnus Carlson in the bullet and it's
truly amazing the way that Magnus can
adjust his type of game based on the
match situation based on the time
control at the beginning of the match he
was more tactical we had some Italians
uh we had a night or but then as he
settled into the lead he started playing
more positionally and then as we
transitioned to the bullet he started
playing purely on intuition he sends the
vidit is a little bit less practiced at
bullet Robert and so he accelerated his
pace of play to really accentuate I
think vidit's lack of experience it's
worked incredibly and man oh man is he a
runaway train when the man is on form
do you see this underneath our cameras
Dania that the overall accuracy Carlson
Lee's 92.8 to 91.4 that makes sense but
in three plus one wow then it was
slightly more accurate than Magnus was
that was four to four in that time
Patrol but to say you played more
accurately than Magnus and you tied the
score in the three plus one that is
something to be proud of absolutely we
sing magnus's praises and for very good
reason the man deserves uh every plot it
imaginable but so does vid it the final
score of this match is not going to
represent how close it was but it was at
times a single win away from getting
this to a two-point match he was oh so
close and some of the victories he
scored he can really hang his hat on as
we take a look at the current scoreboard
it is unfortunately forbidden pulling
away from him it's a seven point lead
yeah there was a 4-4 sandwich there with
the 6-3 in the longest time of chill in
Magnus favor it's currently four and a
half in the bullet in magnus's favor at
the Norwegian the world number one he is
cruising at least on the scoreboard but
the match has been very close throughout
until we got to the bullet
I think it's amazing how this year
already in the SBT we're seeing some
players in sparkling form I think in
years past sometimes the Forum has been
a little bit topsy-turvy but let's
identify a couple of players who've
shown sparkling form thus far Magnus
Carlson obviously today uh we saw
Fabiano caruano who's been in great form
for a while nihal Serene mvl crushing
through the morning match I can't
believe that was today Robert we've got
so many players in great form and you
know what that promises it promises some
epic final matches in the SEC this year
well this I think the standout performer
of the opening matches thus far has to
be Maxine versus the way he dominated
gukesh it was never close there was not
any shakiness to Maxim's play but we
have seen other great performers make
their way through to the quarterfinals
Magnus Carlson will be a quarterfinalist
it would seem only 13 minutes remain in
the overall match clock and with the
score a seven point lead for Magnus he
would have to lose every game and lose
some pretty quickly for to be able to
mount a comeback it's mathematically
possible Magnus is certainly not
planning
to take his foot off the gas pedal
moreover he his openings are becoming
more and more combative as he trots out
a benoni but only one of the best bullet
openings because it's so easy to play
there's so many tactical ideas and the
main idea of course is to prepare B6 B5
but you always have to watch out for the
health of your D6 spawn this is the main
drawback Robert of the benoni this major
major long-term weakness on D6
that's a hundred percent the case and
that's why black first but a rook today
to protect upon now the Queen's over on
B7 B5 is next so Vidant went G4 that
might expose his King I don't see what's
next for that g pawn and I clearly see
what Magnus has the sword for did it man
and once these pawns start to roll it's
like a roller coaster going down the
hill there is nothing in this world that
can stop those pawns from steamrolling
White on the queen side you're gonna see
Magnus soon enough I think pushing C4
creating a little envelope for his
Knight on C5 he knows all of these ideas
down pat and he's got 56 seconds on his
clock as he's doing that
more than double did its time an easier
position to play for black the a file
open and now under blacks control and C3
anybody with B4 next give me a protected
pass Pawn
C3 bit it saying no no no you are not
going to support that passer
unfortunately for white that Bishop is
plenty uh to support C3 safely and now
Magnus is going after that pawn on B4
with everything that he's got
is he really gonna put his Rook on C4 oh
no oh no
that is sad for white you just can't
protect B4 that one little Pawn on B5
defends both ropes if only you could
replace the queen on B3 with a pawn
that's true but what I find by vid it
there he went Rook to A1 and why is this
so good for black
apparently there's a ridiculous tactic
that's never going to happen with Knight
takes before if Magnus plays that move I
leave wait what's the point 1964 Knight
he played it
I'm leaving oh
no
Bishop C4 Queen takes off three
and now Bishop D4 sets up the main
thread on G1 he's found that too and
Avid has to abandon the Knight and that
ends the combination
the queen has only one Escape square and
it's enough
Rook B2 and it's over
this was a masterpiece like we were
talking about how great some of the
other games were this one Sublime
that would have taken me 30 minutes and
there'd be absolutely no guarantee that
I would see that move Knight takes B4
are you kidding me and Bishop C4 would
have gotten mated like this black
doesn't even need the Knight who needs
the knights who needs anything except
Magnus Carlson's brilliancies
foreign
I'm speechless that was so exceptional
to play in that tactical sequence to
deliver a mating attack against vidis
King wow wow wow
and he didn't even need any time he
ended the game with 30 seconds on his
clock Magnus is in Sublime form as you
put it and a jababa London I like what I
see
that was just a brilliant I can't get
out of my head so we all know this next
game I'm gonna force myself to move on
just like many people in the chat in
their relationship sorry I shouldn't say
I'll talk about like things like that
but here we see that the position is one
that resembles a well it did resemble a
caracon for a moment now there's a Pawn
on C6 and Dania I mean this match
clearly in magnus's favor but Vivid he
will try to fight for those last few
games
he will indeed and I think Chad is
holding me to my promise of leaving the
commentary
um I honestly did not mean that for
dramatic effect I thought there was no
way Agnes would find Knight takes before
because we saw that it was the best move
and at least speaking for myself I still
didn't understand it so how can somebody
find it within the confines of a bullet
game and calculate it out well that is
why there's only one person on the
planet named Magnus Carls and actually
there's probably more than one but
there's only one of these Magnus
Carlsons yeah Magnus Carlsen number one
rated player in the world uh what a find
that was by him and Bennett is still
playing well despite the match score
getting away from him the level of play
from Vivint has been really high it's
just unfortunate for him that he's
playing as Magnus Carlsen absolutely and
if it should hold his head up high like
I said he scored some victories he was
completely even with the Magnus for 60
minutes 60. in the three plus one time
control he was just lacking a little bit
at the beginning of the match and
obviously the bullet has been all
Carlson there is just nothing anybody
can do when Magnus displays this kind of
form in the one minute time control
and in this game here we see that it's
even material both sides have Bishop two
Rooks and six pawns but Magnus is trying
to Spring free a passer on the queen
side with a move like B5 and then
perhaps C5
and just to quickly round off the topic
someone in the chat said that that
resembled a Mickey Hill's Hall game
absolutely tall did have a couple of
brilliances in the modern benoni so I
really think that that is a good
parallel to draw tall would definitely
be proud of that one
yes and we often say Mikhail tall when
we see a tactical game but as you
mentioned an opening that he was fond of
he put some great successes in and in
this game here Dania we have an end game
where it's Rook Bishop excuse me two
Rooks bishop and five per side the
center is opening up I'm starting to
like did his position in the end game
I'm liking that its position as well you
can take on E5 that's a check that gives
you a Tempo to escape the possibility of
a fork vid it activates his Rooker okay
too threatening Bishop G4 threatening
Bishop takes B5 and forcing Magnus to
drop his King all the way back to its
initial Square
and the black king could have gone up to
F4 but instead it goes back to D6 so he
Retreats and the D4 Pawn being loose
over here is there some kind of tactic
with Rook takes E2
there might be in Bishop takes B5 Magnus
playing for a win once again
he wants a rook C7 at some point oh
King F2 apparently is the only winning
move no way
he's gonna find us
is there a Checkmate there is he weaving
a Checkmate now with GPS Rook takes D4
and G3 made and he's gone G3 immediately
wrong move order
yes because the white king is the one
getting mated oh my gosh he came so
close that Magnus I think he just
confused the move order and vidit a
couple of moves away here from getting
his first Victory Rook E2 mate
oh
sexy in his own right
yes Vivid says you get one and I get one
right back that was a nasty checkmating
sequence sure Magnus missed some kind of
mating net of his own hard to spot those
especially in bullet chess but did it at
long last he gets a win in the bullet
absolute Kudos kept trying to fight kept
doing everything within his power to
douse the Flames of Magnus Carlson's
incredible play and he succeeded for
that fleeting moment the match is over
obviously we're purely making cosmetic
changes to the score but the chess is
still so fascinating
it is and though vidic can't win the
match he's making himself and everyone
proud you actually see the featured chat
good job video there are many supporters
of Gujarati I think that the community
predictions well 98 of Max's favorite
unsurprising but I think vidit I mean
he's put up such a marvelous fight he
knew he was the underdog he wanted to
give it his all and this is a
performance to be proud of of course and
I'm a little bit biased because I'm a
big fan of vivid as a person I think
he's just a absolute Class Act and
always has been uh but as a chess player
you know to to put up this kind of fight
not just against Magnus Carlson but
against a Magnus who is in absolute Peak
form is something to be proud of I don't
think there's a single person in the
chat right now who's looking at this
match and saying ah you know I wish it
was somebody else rather than Vivid who
would have given Magnus a better fight
vidit brought the best Magnus out of him
and that takes a very strong player in
his own right
that's right because when Magnus doesn't
win by like 20 points unless you're like
oh he wasn't playing his best chess no
vidit actually had a great day with this
technique throughout with some tactical
flourishes of his own and in this game
right here Dania the pawn on B4 is if
it's Stranded the bishop on E1 is the
only dark Square Bishop on the board I
like White's position although the
engine did not like Knight to B6
is their Bishop takes before intermed so
I guess not
and we're going to get some sort of a
liquidation here white takes on A6 trade
and Bishop G2 oh more craziness for
Magnus
and did it
great that's a great decision because
now in the end game black is up a pawn
but white is the one with the easier
moving passer
you're exactly right Bishop E7 there was
the threat you can play it now
oh Bishop E7 is nice and B4 no he's
gonna take the pawn this is probably
still a draw
it should be but Knights are very tricky
pieces there could be a fork if you're
not looking out for it but that B Pawn
is also quite fast
it is indeed Magnus sticks his Bishop on
B5
and if you get to take that Knight with
your light Square Bishop opposite
colored Bishops should be a very simple
draw and the dark Square control is
clear from White's Bishop
okay Magnus
still playing still trying still
creating chances
oh he's winning now
this is winning
yeah because you're winning
F4 King F5 and unfortunately for white
you can't stop these pawns from pushing
but what is the winning approach here
because there are some positions which
are drawn but I think F and E are
winning you're right the king is going
to head over to
wait but how does this win
King F5 King G14 F3 oh you got around
Luke oh you can't bring your king back
the bishop cut it off nope he came comes
around he wins the game how did he win
this one too and vid it all he can do is
shake his head in admiration with two
and a half minutes remaining we might be
down to our final game
Magnus really can be a table base
sometimes he just knows when to make a
transition a lot of us including myself
or especially myself we're suggesting
that no you can't trade that night for
that Bishop opposite College Bishop that
should be a draw right he says no I have
this scoped out he gets another win and
Dania Vince still playing really well
it's just not going his way down the
final stretch I don't mean this in a
condescending way at all rather you know
to to further our understanding of what
makes Magnus brilliant but it's I think
it's hard to fully grasp uh the extent
of magnus's knowledge until you face him
in let's say you know bullet match
that's when you realize that the guy
makes decisions in a millisecond that
you genuinely might not have been able
to make in a classical game and it's all
based on just such an almost spiritual
feel for the position that's very hard
to describe and you know that is why we
refer to Magnus as a once uh in in a
generation perhaps once in a lifetime
Talent it's that insane feel that almost
never lets him down you mean like in
this game where you hit F5 completely
unprovoked he gives away a pawn and this
takes over all the key squares on the
king side it's not going to be easy for
bit Who's down to 28 seconds in the game
and this night from C3 before I could
even finish my sentence Magnus goes
around to F4 he blunts the black Bishop
with C3 he's playing both positionally
and tactically at the same time as he
drives up the pawn chain his Bishop from
A2 drops back to B1 Perfect Harmony is
being achieved once more and 15 seconds
hasn't even been spent
it's incredible stuff from Magnus will
be our final game as we're now under 30
seconds on the match clock and did it
still putting up a great fight I'm
worried about his clock but I'm not
worried about his play it's been good
stuff from him it's been great stuff
from him Bishop sticks itself on G4 now
H5 has been prevented this is officially
going to be the last game of this
incredible match as Magnus releases the
tension in the center with DC
ugh and it looks like vidit's got a
chance here to score the honor goal in
the final game much like gukesh did
that Bishop on G5 looks pretty trapped I
guess you can steal the F4 Pawn but
after all the swaps white needs to be
very careful that the first rank is
covered and The Rook will slide back
indeed rookie two there is Rook F2 but
it goes with a frontal attack Rook B8
trying to force Rook F2 then I think he
had D4 in mind but Magnus prevents it
with the intermediate Bishop A2
nice move and he plays C4 does videotu
shut that Bishop down but look at the
White Knight returning just in time I
still like the disposition I just don't
like his clock
I don't like his clock either The Rook
swings over to do preventing Knight to
D1 which was a hidden threat
will Magnus involve his Bishop via B1
will he do it now
he does and Knight D1 so you call that
idea it finally happens and Magnus he
said oops missed that impressed but the
D5 Pawn is loose as well he takes B2
Magnus takes D5 and again the clock
situation starting to impact the game
Bishop A2 another great move 95 and
White's winning Rook A7 wins a piece and
Magnus is going to take the last one
wow but C3 is a sudden threat
doesn't go for it or apparently is the
only move
sound
F5
wins the game wins the match
with a night Fork to win another one
Magnus Carlson has officially won this
match 17 and a half to eight and a half
the final score does not do Gujarati
justice but Magnus even though he was
given a fight he's proven that he has
too much money
and it Rhymes to the bullet segment has
left me absolutely speechless that game
with the Knight takes before just
epitomizes the kind of form that Magnus
was in really from the very beginning of
the match there were a couple of bumpy
moments there was some unexpected
turbulence but he had his seat belts on
the entire time Magnus takes this match
by nine total points
so Magnus Carlson with a nine point
match Victory he moves on to the
quarterfinals where he awaits the winner
of a match that has not taken place yet
so we do not know who Madness will
square off against in the next round
which is the quarterfinal so why don't
we pull up our bracket to show you the
quarterfinalists that we do have because
we are almost there we have seen many of
the matches uh be finished we saw Maxine
Buster the Groff win his match earlier
today we know that he will take on nihal
sarin but Maxim while he knows his
opponent Magnus does not know his but
maybe as we see the bracket pulled up
here Yonder Palm she replaced dignity
Wren he takes an argenter guy see Dania
big question if you were back as Carlson
who would you rather face Jan or origin
well there's the chess considerations
but there's also the sort of
psychological considerations Carlson has
already faced Jana pomnishi and I think
that he would take a crack at a Revenge
match against nem I guess nepo would
probably take a crack at a Revenge batch
against Magnus so I selfishly want to
see that one but nepo Arjun is an
amazing match in its own right to round
off a round of 16 matches
well everyone knows what's coming up
next even though we don't know Max's
opponent we will hear from him but
before we do let's take a look at the
Savvy moves presented by coinbase
because we had not just the cool move
not just a great move we had a sexy
Savvy sequence by Magnus Carlson we did
indeed I'm going to pull up that game
and let's rewind to the moment where it
all began this started out as a modern
benoni Magnus involving all of his
pieces in the attack and The Savvy move
comes in this position there is direct
pressure on B4 but this Pawn is
untouchable right Robert right because
white defends it as many times as black
attacks it
well we thought that was the case but
black says Knight takes before and after
night things before you may think that
there's some tactics on the queen side
but full board awareness is essential
and done a queen F2 deserved that other
two exclamation points
and then there was yet another
incredible move Queen F2 was one of them
Bishop takes C4 Queen takes F3 would get
checkmated and the final nail in the
coffin the bishop comes in setting up a
devastating battery forcing the queen
away and after Rook takes B4 it was all
over Magnus recovers the extra piece and
he is up a million pawns on the queen
side what an incredible sequence the
most incredible thing of all is that
this happened in a bullet game
he just could not be stopped could
Magnus Carlson he wins that game he wins
the match but that was really nice stuff
from the number one rated player in the
world so we don't want to leave Magnus
waiting too long so we want to thank
coinbase again and thank you all for
watching the speed test Championship
presented by coinbase but don't go
anywhere ask your questions right now in
chat we may be able to ask Magnus those
very questions we are going to head to
break but when you return to interview
with Magnus Carlson the winner of his
Opening match here in the speeches
Championship presented by coinbase
thank you
smear Jess is coming to chess.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze the hair start
with two jump spells and five free
spells which will charge after five
moves you may cast your spare whenever
you wish before making a regular chest
move jump is a spell cast to one square
wherein if there is a piece on that
square other pieces can jump over the
Charmed piece the freeze spell is cashed
over a three by three square area and
the pieces in this area are temporarily
Frozen in place
and bang your powers of Chess and
surgery to defeat your opponent
see what supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
on September 1st
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
and we return with Magnus Carlson as he
won his Opening match in the VHS
Championship presented by coinbase
Magnus congratulations I know you're
probably keen on watching the Norway vs
Georgia football match but how are you
feeling about the Massachusetts had
against vidit
no it's okay I didn't have any
particular expectations today
um
I didn't particularly uh you know uh
didn't particularly feel feel uh like
I was in great great shape so it was
just about
getting through
um I thought he did well
um
didn't really feel like I was out
playing him ever
um
the games that I won were mostly uh
either some time scrambles or some
random tricks so I yeah I think he he
played really well most most of the time
but um yeah overall it was a bit of a
bit of a slog but
um I think
um
it was never too much in doubt
uh Magnus a quick question about
openings uh in the second game you
trotted out a night ORF uh after that
you started playing more positionally
with both colors some London's and E4 E5
you even tried out of French to what
degree are your opening choices in this
match as well as the SCC at large uh the
product of pre-planning uh and to what
degree is it just sort of a spur of the
moment decision based on how the magic
goes
yeah I actually had a good position in
the the night or if I just misplayed it
uh later uh I would say
um I mean there's as much I should
I mean it's it's really one of the perks
of I think being specifically the one or
two seed that
your huge favorite and uh in the first
match so I didn't do any prep for for
this one uh but I probably will for
uh at least a bit for subsequent matches
so I thought let's move around a bit but
I I also know he's strong in the opening
so it's it's kind of hard to
um
hard to get to to him too much but yeah
I was just moving moving around uh I
wasn't trying to play anything to
uh too crazy or and sound just
uh moving around a bit
and Magnus you've had great success in
the last couple months you won two
Champions chess tour events you won a
grand Chester rapid and blitzy of course
won the World Cup do you feel like
you're really hitting your stride at
this moment this year
foreign
comes and goes a little bit
um
so you know sometimes
um sometimes I win even when I'm not
playing well you know
sometimes like
um
in the not in this Championship story
about but the event before I both play
really well and I win and sometimes I um
I play okay and I still went
um like I mean today for instance
it was just um dead work really
um I just came home yesterday
um
a little bit jet-like a little bit tired
so
um but um
I think in general
my chest shape is more or less okay and
[Music]
um
yeah as long as I uh sort of raise my
level a bit for the subsequent matches I
should be in should be a good trip
uh Magnus apart from a couple sparkling
tactical games you also converted a
couple of equal end games into wins and
even pulled out uh wins out of a couple
worse end games uh for aspiring players
in the chat uh could you share uh a
particular player or maybe a book that
uh inspired you to study and improve
your end games uh when you were uh in
your beginning stages of your career
yeah I think uh fundamental chess
Endings by uh Miller and Dan pressed uh
helped me quite a bit
when I was around
11 12 apart from that
um
I think
there are a lot of uh
um
yeah a lot of playing end games it's
just positional understanding and
perseverance and those usually come with
um with experience they're they're not
so hard they're not so easy to uh to
teach
um but I wouldn't say that I
particularly excelled in that
regard I mean I did win a few but um I
think I'd normally expect to win
more end games tonight than I did today
and Magnus we did have some featured
chat questions we asked them uh for
anything you want to ask you and one
question from gaming hi Lina is what
does the p on your hat stand for because
you're sporting that cap earlier
I'm not sure but it's
um it's for sure golf related it's like
Puma golf wear
got it
um another chat question from Ravine
Dune uh Magnus your views on hyper
bullet 32nd as a potential time control
in the next SCC
um I don't really
I don't really see the points
to be honest like one one is uh it's a
good game so we're gonna play 30 Seconds
without
increments
I mean I think
for me
um 30 second chances
um only sort of playable on
other online servers
makes makes sense Magnus and uh one last
question from the chat this one I I like
this one from Kitty fleet commander they
ask how do you achieve such composure
moving instantly confidently and
accurately
um yeah
sometimes I do that but
like today I was at times at least
trying to move instantly and confidently
and because I didn't think I would be
able to play accurately
of course when it all comes together it
looks very good but um yeah I wouldn't
wouldn't say that happened today and as
for a composure I probably kept my
conversion like a little bit better in
scrambles than he did but I wasn't
really happy with my my planner so yeah
thanks a lot for
the nice words but the whoever wrote
that question but I don't think it's um
it's suitable for today
well Magnus you definitely astounded
many of the fans out there we will let
you get your rest watch that Norway uh
football match I'm sure you're uh
excited to see the successes from your
native team but we'll see you next match
we don't know who you're going to play
between Arjun and nepo I guess before we
let you go do you have a preference on
who to face
I think
um
I think Giannis
um is a more interesting opponent
uh but I feel like the match is pretty
open like
obviously honest um he's a better player
but he's extremely tiltable so
um if Arjun can can get going at some
point it's um completely open
okay well thank you so much Magnus
congrats once again and we'll see you
soon for your next match congrats
yeah thank you
and that is the world number one Magnus
Carlson who takes down Gujarati 17 and a
half to eight and a half and as you see
14 wins in magnus's favor and 92.7
average accuracy and Donya 98.8 highest
accuracy for Magnus gives electric
throughout I mean 92.7 across three time
controls including bullet that's crazy
and a big shout out of it it's staying
over 90 as well and we've almost rounded
out our quarter final bracket there's
one slot that remains to be filled and
we will have nepo against Arjun in our
final round of 16 matchup it's gonna be
an incredible one Magnus Carlson I'm
sure is going to watch that one with
baited breath
yes and Magnus I'm sure he's gonna go
watch the Norway Georgia match football
match for the uh it seems like Norway is
up two goals he'll be a happy camper but
he is as he said anticipating Jana
pomshi as the favorite against Arjun era
geisie he looks forward to a rematch
from the 2021 World Chess Championship
against Jana palmchi and done it he said
that young he's the stronger player but
he's tiltable
yeah he said he's eminently he's
extremely tiltable and he is and that's
going to be a really interesting Battle
of the generations I'm looking forward
to that one I'm looking forward to all
of the quarterfinals matchups Robert and
if they're going to be anything like the
matches we saw today from morning to
evening
I think we're in for treat after treat
well we are definitely going to be
treated to a matchup tomorrow it will be
Wesley versus alireza but before we say
goodbye to everybody and say see you
then we do want to give these two
players here Ali Reza and Wesley they're
due Donna I'm gonna put you on the spot
right now
pick a favorite
listen I think normally I would pick
alireza but he was very top seed servy
in his form against undraken he almost
lost that match I think if he doesn't
improve his form the one that he showed
against Dimitri I'm gonna have to go
with Wesley it's all going to depend on
the form that Ali Reza shows I can't
wait for the match though it's going to
be a really fun one don't miss it
it's going to be fun indeed Wesley
struggled against Levon down the stretch
but he already had a pretty huge lead
thanks to his Blitz prowess so it's
going to be a closely contested batch we
will see that tomorrow but before I say
goodbye I want to give a shout out to a
very special event near and dear to our
hearts calling all chess clubs you are
eligible to participate in Judith
polgar's chess connects us Championship
clubs from all over the world are
invited to nominate four players to
compete in the online event on October
14th for the chance to win prizes from
chess.com chessable and Judith Polgar
herself join us in celebrating the game
that connects us all use the command
chess connects in chat to learn more
Dania Judy Polgar what a star what an
awesome player and and maybe an even
better Ambassador for the game
absolutely love Judith um obviously her
incredible playing career her
commentating career now her career as
you put it as HS Ambassador a great time
to be alive we've got so many really
wholesome figures uh carrying forward
chess on so many different levels
spreading it to so many different people
and I really really reinforces the idea
that this is the Golden Age of Chess not
least because we've got the SEC to watch
these are the golden few months of Chess
and tomorrow the festivities continue
they do indeed so get a nice rest enjoy
yourself but tomorrow we'll be back for
another day another match in the speed
Chess Championship presented by coinbase
thanks so much to coinbase for sponsors
event thanks to all of you for being
here with us Dania thanks and I'll see
you tomorrow see you then everybody it's
Wesley for Sally Raza
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you